[Music]
[Music]
so
me
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
check
my check
happy sunday
happy father's day
crown what's going on excuse me while i
wake up
a little tired a little tired over here
we hear what's going on people
talk to the round right quick let's
[Music]
happy father's day to the patriarchs all
at movies manic 96 what's going on talk
talk to you arcade don't know if it's
the same demo for pat oh wrestling
wrestle quest demos on steve okay okay
okay thank you now i'm omar what's going
on hollywood rules what's up delilah hd
what's going on what's up says fuzzy
i'm over i i gotta stop slandering uh
forza it look really good
so fuzzy you got that i bet you got that
i knew it was gonna look good but it
looked
[Music]
what's up
y'all giving me life brett bingham
what's going on y'all giving me life a
little tired today
a lot of a lot of lawyers might be
we got to see what's going on there's a
lot going on last minute so i'm going to
be fully transparent with the realm
so
king is all day
but he will with the father's day game
but he will be checking in
uh
jazz is not feeling well
so you know we gave jazz the um the time
you know so
jazz might come through next week just
to be honest with y'all the grant's
ready to be good soft should be good
addict is not
i don't know where to get
that i knew it he told he talked to me
he wasn't feeling last night so it's
gonna be an interesting show you know
what i said but i got to be fully
transparent yes lord solve will be here
or i saw him up so that should be good
you know what i'm saying and then rand i
spoke to so we should be good on that
but i always got to be transparent with
y'all with offering things to the
product you know what i'm saying but i
appreciate y'all so we still gotta have
some fun a lot of stuff to talk about
crazy crazy things but yeah king didn't
say he's checking in remotely so it's
not like we're gonna lose king i just
don't know what time he's coming
in as long as you don't wear them damn
crocs i'm good keep them crocs out of
here
he willing right now he out of pocket he
that's a vibe that's egregious it's a
it's a violation of fashion standards i
gotta talk to my man good shout out to
y'all for signing the change that
opposite petition to get on king croc
right is he loose out here this is crazy
this is crazy you don't even see your
brothers go down this this dark path
he going down the dark path right now
it's up to us as a community to get the
swaggy king back we like swaggy you know
what i'm saying but this was going on
this grandfather at the barbecue this
uncle
oh i can't with the rainbow crocs don't
shout out to the rainbow but i'm just
saying but like come on king we gotta do
better so i know he's gonna come in here
with them cracks cause he on vacation i
think he's on the beach somewhere so i'm
bracing myself
anyway enough king slander shout out to
my bro hey live your life bro i ain't
mad at you
i just gotta mess with you
look we'll be back i'll see if i can uh
get the rest of the lords up in here we
have we got a good show we have some fun
i miss talking to y'all i feel like i
haven't talked to y'all in a minute and
i will be back
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'd be keeping these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
coastal um
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you i ain't here to boil you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the snapple and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social love
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
i'm better than money because you can
bank on me being accountable i know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the snapple and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they wanna compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm
[Music]
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
um
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
who
let's do that again
and we are live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line this is that
standard this is what we use right now
kind of our caffeine substitute and what
we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advanced gg.com use code iron lord on
the checkout this is something i use all
the time gotta support advanced gg great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration line for those who
don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lord
cognito here iron law podcast
peace
[Music]
for attic if i can imagine it's cool to
get you some advice and invite your girl
to your squadron cause if you don't give
her that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny work to kind of who cares if
you fly if you're still a mosquito you
swearing away something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right all right mic check my check
talk to the people so i'll talk to the
people
what up
what's going on c levels levels is good
friends make sure you're good too
we're good we're always good we're
always good we're always good we got a
little
little situation in the back
there we go there's our bottom bar there
we go all right here we go a little bit
professional tom is watching y'all get
put your best one
and we are live happy father's day to
all the patriarchs out there salute in
the realm we really respect and your
service is greatly appreciated so salute
to y'all and welcome to the iron lords
podcast llc and also live on
lordsofgaming.net
episode number 261 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day i'm very excited
about our special guest and we have the
xbox showcase aftermath and extended
showcase recap
final fantasy 7 skips xbox
and playstation now game losses to
discuss so we're gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only a solid friend of the realm of the
iop but in my opinion represents the
gold standard on objectivity
thought-provoking discussion and clear
and concise delivery in video form
introducing
the creator and host of the randolph 19
youtube channel and the co-host of the
xbox 2 podcast
the lord of gamer score and the wheel of
time
rarely quoted for breaking news on his
own podcast
it is the leader of the deep fake xbox
predictions movement
live from the south side of the shop
where we always reminisce about a
healthy d rose and those epic stacey
king call outs
my man
lord randolph thorne 19 how we doing sir
cog i did not know i was gonna get the
intro today i wasn't expecting it and
the streets what the streets were
talking i mean you know you you even
included the wheel of time so that
that's a plus intro
yeah we don't get that round oh no here
we go you guys don't get it but you know
this is this is gonna be our time to
shine we got xbox three going on right
here
right we got the xbox three
no king david and no lord attic holding
us back
no no shilling today
[Laughter]
we'll be joining here
bush is for attic we gotta get my
butcher's emoji right now i don't know
what's going on i gave him his call and
he requested
so
alex in the bushes what's that yeah man
what's up with you man what you've been
playing
uh you know i'm i'm almost finished with
the quarry
on uh the series x
i'm a big fan of the supermassive games
um this this one is very interesting i
think it's better than their dark
pictures games really
but maybe
not as good as until dawn like i still
think until dawn is probably their best
game
uh but this one does kind of approach it
in some areas like something you ever
play one of these games it's like this
like horror game and stuff some of the
characters just act all stupid and
you're just kind of like come on really
yeah
you're just like this person would not
act like this in this real scenario and
stuff but
barry where's barry
so i know i've been enjoying i've been
drawing the quarry a lot and i've also
been playing a little bit of uh
that retro goodness oh yes tmnt
shredders revenge
you know me me and code eastwood uh we
uh we played some co-op
uh you can play up to six people
we was just me and him i do want to try
it out when six people because even with
just two
became so good it's so crazy
man it is a throwback to those uh
turtles arcade games but it's it's still
very modern yes and it is an absolute
back you guys have to play yeah you have
to play it yeah we the plan is we're
playing with saturday for all the lords
yeah obviously king he has she's
traveling he's in the beat somewhere
with those
those crimes
he's got a movement now like that's like
hashtag king croc but but anyways so the
plan was to do all four of us because i
i i want to play it so bad bro i was
looking at xbox 2 i'm looking at your
footage
i'm like dad it looks so [ __ ] temple
always kills it we had the opportunity
to always interview them they've got the
retro feel down they killed it to rage
we knew they were going to kill it with
tmnt when we went to cover it so what i
saw the foolish who who had michelangelo
who eleanor that was me my mikey's
always been my favorite turtle so always
gotta pick him
why is he is he not yours he says
michelangelo not yours you know what's
funny i don't remember i think i was a
donatello guy i think i was a dawn guy
but you just like donatello because he's
got the reach yeah he's got he's got the
he's got he's got the cheese the cheese
moves but the long range
the wrath of michael you're too
dangerous y'all got to get in the
mix now i have a salute to them my
bike's always been the fun one on the
show yeah
so yeah you already know and of course
we are we're down one a member of the
xbox two but salute to just caught it
man you know saying let the man rest up
he's doing a lot we will reconvene with
jazz my brother salute always loved
manny the guy's doing a ton of things
but we'll get him back and uh we got the
four we ain't got four yeah yeah you got
the two horsemen we got the three
yeah
we got we got uh two horsemen of gaming
in the building you know saying the new
xbox three right now you know what i'm
saying but of course we have the most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single-player selfish
experience and also the sastradamus the
lord of clarity and lord patron of the
iron bank my man lord sovereign how are
we doing sir i'm good man i'm telling
you happy father's day to all
you know i was not going you know i said
i wasn't going to be here for father's
day but uh since i have
a spotty uh attendance record lately
but yeah um so hopefully i'm kind of
back you know fully moved in just trying
to get out of minimal boxes now yeah
yeah so um but yeah everything's good um
in terms of uh
shout out actually shout out to the team
over at uh
interior night uh we got cog and i got
to interview them a little bit was it
was it earlier this week last week uh
about as dusk falls yeah that's how time
flies i don't remember what week it was
um
fantastic uh narrative based game it
looks like it's gonna be a super fun
experience especially with uh in in the
multiplayer mode so
check out that interview if you haven't
seen it yet
fantastic little game i'm excited for
for that game to come out up on podcast
right now exclusive yeah
playlist go check that out
and then apart from that i still haven't
connected my my consoles yet so not even
little man so i did but so what i had to
do what i always do i had to go yeah i
had to go spend that money on that
switch man i could not oh it's red
favorite
we talk about the switch
right here what's up
what a console
number one mpd covered in hot shavings
that's right man stop hating ran
my switch is my switch isn't is isn't
even hooked up anymore oh damn it
doesn't even need to be because xbox got
that silk song baby
that was when i saw that i was like oh
bro you know what's so crazy about the
social world it was impressive because i
remember covering that in 2019 e3 in the
nintendo section yeah
all things pointed to that being
exclusive to them for a time yeah and uh
phil came in with the bag very smart
yeah
you know uh i was gonna say saab's
looking a little different he's missing
a couple knees there kyle
listen man it's it's rare in when i get
my brother like you gotta stay late yeah
i don't i don't give up knees he does
not like he's one of the smartest people
i know i'm known as kids third grade
it's it's rare to get him like i'm like
finally like i feel like he's never
wrong like he's been on fire
bro like you had the activision joint
before everybody yeah yeah the activism
was it was just one of those things like
they're so in the dregs why not like
just give it a shot who knows right
it happened but
the thing about the the
the uh the persona stuff
is that these guys you know although
they're under the the sega umbrella
they're very much kind of an island unto
themselves and for whatever reason it
just felt like they you know when if
sega had come to be like hey man what's
up with these games on xbox it felt like
they were like no no way
you can't tell us what to do can't tell
us what to do you own us but you get to
and
so it really felt like for whatever
reason they just did not see the value
in putting it on xbox and then
apparently the bag was dropped off a
very big nice bag
but i think i mean it it opens up the
door for so much more so i'm glad about
that because again we had
atlas games on 360. so it is you know
i'm happy that's the thing so on switch
yes i got that shredder's revenge i had
to impose i had to impose my uh my my
gaming sensibilities on my niece and
nephew so i just i just bought them oh i
know you y'all gonna play would be
not gonna
my nephew they didn't they didn't call
me to be like thank you theo nothing
nothing so i called him like hey what's
going on did you get something new
they're like oh yeah i'm like oh really
oh no the disrespect of the retro
goodness disrespected the rest so then
my nephew eventually i'm just kidding i
do about it whatever that he's like i
haven't played it yet so he goes and
then he plays it he calls me this
morning at 10 a.m i am knocked out
because i went to bed so late and i'm
like he's like deal do you know it only
has 15 stages i finished it
like i love how it's only 15.
i'm like the point is replayability i'll
call you later
he's like i don't know i want to play
this again i'm like great that's fine
and my niece forget it she hasn't even
contacted me once so wow yeah yeah how
crazy that game was in the arcade for us
back in the day so it's a generational
gap it is because he doesn't on he
doesn't know what that is at all like i
tell him hey you had to stand in front
of this machine and put quarters in to
keep playing he's like are you stupid no
i'm not gonna do that i'm gonna play
fortnite and you know whatever
so yeah so but he seemed like he enjoyed
it though so i have to i have to teach
him
you know it's about replayability with
these games like play it with another
with another person yeah right exactly
so i'm a mikey guy too so i've been
playing with mikey
oh man
you know what it is these games when you
look back at turtles in time the
original turtles they're simplistic in
terms of combos and stuff like that
they're fairly simplistic
what tribute does and what the temu does
is that they take that formula and then
modernize it and expand upon it yes they
did it with suture h4
with this even more so like the combos
that you have the super moves like it
really is a beautiful thing at first the
only thing that threw me off a little
bit was that they shrunk the characters
a little bit and we noticed that from
the beginning i was like why don't they
make the characters as tall as they are
in the arcade
yeah but you get over that very quickly
but the game is it's just a joy it
really is a joy so yeah i've bought it
three times and i have yet to play it on
xbox
come on
you know what i know what i saw there
there are people giving like opinions of
what they should uh do next right
you got streets of rage four which was
great
you got turtles
people were saying how about that x-men
oh you do one of
i mean these are guys that they that the
pedigree that they have they can do they
can keep doing the arcade stuff right
but they can even go back in and take a
game like gun star heroes like a
treasure game that doesn't even exist
anymore and take that and bring it to
the next level or go back and make like
a
guardian heroes like guardian heroes
when it came to beat em up it was
probably it had a it's a beat em up with
rpg sensibilities right kind of in the
vein of the capcom d and d
side-scrolling things games
those games had again a lot more
mechanics in terms of the combat
mechanics in terms of like magic
mechanics and stuff like that but again
with the pedigree these guys have they i
mean sky's the limit when it comes to
coming back to that stuff and they said
it in an interview i think uh they were
talking to ign i believe
and they said like
you know we were lucky to get the tmnt
license but if not all everything you
see in this game would have been for a
property that we were creating for
ourselves right so that's not off the
table either for for them to make their
own brand new property which is super
exciting for me because again
the expertise there is insane and you
don't see pixel art like this anymore
like just the attention of d they really
you know what i like is that they do
such a good job in reference to the
source material but with like you said a
modern flair that publishers
are like trusting them like for sega to
trust you and then call their game
streets of rage four when it technically
wasn't made by them so to speak that's a
big deal but i think fred's on fire with
that x-men x-men i mean x-men is a
my goodness you think of going back what
was your guys's favorite
uh brawler arcade machine back in the
day yeah i take it back bro i mean i was
from the double dragon double
i mean if you think about it now it
wasn't a great game but it was just like
you know
that's what it was like it was double
dragon like yeah
uh mine i think mine
has to be the simpsons oh i'm selling so
much money into that man
there was a so there was a there's a
a school near us that every summer would
have the carnival would come in right
right
and
so we'd all go except i wouldn't ride
into the rides because in the gymnasium
they would have all the arcades set up
and i just would spend the entire night
in the arcades playing simpsons playing
turtles
uh playing like you know the aliens
versus predator ones yeah shout out to
firestar he got um i mean um mr m final
fight was serious oh final fight
that was good
it's amazing but yeah
do you remember the punisher one
there's a punisher one um what the heck
was the other one obviously captain
america and the avengers that was fun
i thought about that one yeah they had a
lot of us man
yeah that's the only thing i've been
able to place i've yet to i can't my
consoles are buried somewhere i got to
find out again you know how that moving
though you already know and of course
we've got the gaming ninja himself the
shinobi lord cognito spreading that
realness to the realm of the iop not
telling what you want to hear but what
you need to hear shout out to defiantly
do shout out to mr maddie plays got that
up right now if you missed it we're
talking about maddie's going through it
man final fantasy fallout 5. see the
cops they agree they're upset you know
the potential of when fallout could come
is like killing my boy so he's going we
tried telling him kind of trying to be
like hey man fallout 5 20 32 20 31 and
he was like
before then and he was like what about
new vegas too and it's just like man
well
i mean when could they get to it
realistically even if they could 2028
you're looking for a long time
and we had a great discussion on the
thought process behind that and what
could possibly done and stuff like that
so that's a good one and then we he's
gonna get killed for he some of his
habits there's a question y'all gonna
know what it is
maddie's habits that's all go check that
out it's a big debate on that um shout
out to the last one yeah maddie's got
some things that they gonna kill him for
and i was like yeah put that in there
for next week i want to see what the
community's saying about the size
besides the macaroni the size of
macaroni with a spoon besides ketchup on
back or whatever
maddie this one is might go viral how
crazy about it
it's not good he just gangsta with it
like i never heard nobody do this within
the bathroom i'm not gonna spoil it
y'all go check that out it's lit um
shout out to the last word man i want to
shout out the last word you know it's
our little destiny podcast that you know
started just being e we're all
flashpoint and then it expanded we got
travis you know what i'm saying on it
but uh it was a big episode for us
because obviously we love this damn you
know saying destiny so much i lost
podcast was founded off of that and then
um obviously we had people like brandon
like we like you but you guys talk only
destiny and i don't want to hear that
so that's that's the last word was
created but uh salute to this episode we
have bungie on we had bungee on we had
uh
absolute fantastic learning behind the
scene how the game is made how they
structure the narrative how they do
things in conjunction with a season
versus expansion highly recommended it's
up for iop right now go check that out
he's in there for at least the first 45
minutes to an hour you can really learn
a lot you know what i'm saying from a
development standpoint so check that out
also we went to gcx so i got to meet
travis and e again in the flesh that was
cool he called me gears of war
characters
he's like you don't realize how big they
are until you're next to them
so we got a big shout out to the
champion shout out to t travis is like
real thin like yeah
and he's short so it's fun i was like
yeah come here let me squeeze you and
touch around somewhere you know what i
said so yeah shout out to gcx shout out
to everybody that pulled up met so many
people at gcx man the list goes on shout
out to everybody of course dj orals was
in the building the destiny besties
salute you know what i'm saying all my
crew back for dead is in there i met him
and his beautiful wife salute everybody
that pulled up we had a good time as far
as gaming um yeah man i've been
obviously with the destiny stuff i
finished the duality dungeon absolutely
fantastic go check that out strong
narrative from the leviathan um
you know my vr kick demille's new
content is out curse of the serpent lord
is amazing
look i know people oh you're just saying
that because you're vr now listen
i'm telling y'all right now as far as
turn back i wish jess was here because i
wanted to ask him something as far as
turn base i had gears tactics as like
the the hottest new turn-based game
right
devio man
yo
i mean you know the the cooperative
aspect some of the best boss battles
i've ever seen in turn basically against
tactics got some good boss battles but
yeah i gotta i gotta salute them they
got a pc port out for my non um you know
what is it we call them the flat
earthers what are we calling people what
are they called the uh the pancakes
yeah pancake guys yeah yeah okay asante
in the building metro that's right
madame gta shout out to ksanti the yo
you know he's um captain keys man right
you know you ain't know from halo way
for this series he's a dead rigger
but anyways who he is
dead
i know they were saying this on twitter
i remember they were saying this that he
was a dead ringer for the captain keys
from the show yeah shout out to dog
chalice stevio's bloody fantastic you
already know yes salute yeah it is
really good it's so good like i'm at the
point right now i'm on a campaign the pc
ports out
xbox
yo fail make the call let's get that
port going on next my xbox gamers need
to know about demio i'm telling you
shout out to resolution games they're
killing it and then um like solve what
you said um as dust falls man we got a
chance to to meet interior knight the
developers you know say up in the city
um really pleasant surprise you know
what i'm saying i didn't i know that was
like a in the corner game for me because
i like those telltale types experience
but uh very well done great art style
you know what i'm saying now i'm not
gonna sit there and say oh it's full
motion and all that it's kind of like
stills but like done in a way where
every 20 seconds there's choices that
has to be made you can play up to eight
players ran this is going to be huge
for xcloud
mobile
streaming yeah streaming because what it
is is you could hand your mom to your
phone a phone she could play she didn't
even need a controller right
then what it is it's got this override
system so we're playing it together and
choices got to be made but i'm like yo i
don't agree with this we need to do this
and it it it judges you at the end as
like what type of person you are you're
a loyal person you put family above this
that the third and true mass effect
level choice is where like the paths are
structured like there's like multiple
endings in the game there's different
timelines in the game like this game is
way deeper it's not as simple as people
think it is yes i hope they as long as
this narrative is good and compelling if
they knocked if they pulled that off
they got one and i see why xbox global
problems should do it because it fits in
the ethos right it and then the twitch
streaming as does falls y'all keep an
eye out for asda fall and the last thing
i think i could talk about i don't think
there's no nda on noraka naraka's um
playpoint the demo is out got a chance
to play that
i i like a lot a lot of potential there
so check that out um and uh yeah let's
get this super chat um so if we can
let's do a little catch up
got these super chats you got booty
member for 11 months happy father's day
to all the real fathers out here that
have a wonderful and blessed day enough
respect to each and every one to you as
well sir thank you brother
my brother let me oh i don't know who
you are let me play with you
let's go what he got to say five dollar
super chat happy father's day psalm what
should i get you as a present daddy
oh man his dad is here
[Laughter]
steam deck would be nice
don't play with that bad emotion song
you out here mary
don't lead him on don't leave him
shout out y'all he be here he'll be so
happy with song that's really hilarious
shout out to cannot play with your joy
[Laughter]
we got big mad mo member for 24 months
thank you sir keep doing what y'all
doing happy father's day to all the dads
out there and you as well brother
absolute and we got black ronin 357
remember for 14 months happy father's
day and june teen to the realm xbox
showcase was a b-plus okay okay absolute
salute
and we got the homie oh lords of
gaming's finest big cloud gaming
remember for 16 months let's go we in
here salute to the realm to do as well
brother no that's not the big cloud
amazing amazing interview up right now
on lords of gaming.net believe the uh
blizzard uh fx director correct me if
i'm wrong big cloud tremendous interview
you're always killing it killing it with
its own interviews gotta slew
an absolute great addition to the lords
of gaming.net team so salute to him
shout out let's put the crest in the
chat for gerald mack welcome to lord
silver thank you my brother you know
j-mac always in there rubbing it back
put those crush in the chat and uh we're
caught up we're good no doubt so with
the little boxing burger in the what's
up
what's up brother you still gonna be
archimedes to me i don't care
yeah thanks for the invite man i was
lying in my kids a baby pool because it
is incredibly
hot
and
uh so that's why i needed five minutes
to dress and
we got presentable the world what is the
world of gaming what are we doing what's
the poster podcast so let's get a shout
out to the podcast right quick man
yeah i'm hosting the world of gaming um
weekly podcast every thursday at 2 p.m
eastern or 7 p.m uk time okay
um having each and every week different
guests we talk about all things gaming
technology news and stuff and we always
have a good time and uh
yeah rent has been on the show for
example indeed in india it was a good
show yeah yeah thank you
no doubt good to have you buddy pull it
up
it's funny that you say be presentable
because my my wife was like you're not
podcasting in your underwear go put on
something
i like that i like that
saluda you already know oh real quick in
a word from our sponsor shout out to
advanced gg yo make sure y'all get that
up that house
which one is that this is the phone it's
the split gate it's the split gate joint
focus the rocket pop absolutely
fantastic coffee substitute you don't
like coffee you know i'm saying you want
to get you want to be up for your long
gaming session get that focus and then
of course for my workout guys and if
you're not workout guy we got the energy
line dream team punch is absolutely
amazing delicious one of my favorite
flavors right now go check that out link
is in the description as well as on
pinned in the chat 20 off and last but
not least for those who don't like
energy drinks no sugar no caffeine on
that get that hydration y'all hydration
is literally like a gatorade like a with
electrolytes in it so pretty much
there's none of that extra stuff any
caffeine no caffeine for the people who
don't wanted that no caffeine so
father's day special 20 off cold island
yes i'm pushing powder yes shout out i'm
pushing that p go get that you already
know i'm doing it wrong i'm doing it
wrong cause i'm doing the coffee and
then i'm doing this oh what you're doing
to call me did you do the energy yeah
hell yeah all right slow down on your
powder sir slow down on your pants no no
morning no more than one scoop per eight
ounces of water you know what i'm saying
one yeah yeah slow down put two in there
a little too much powder baby wipe your
nose
but
after that there we go
no more two scoops for 16 ounces no more
than two scoops for a day and that's it
that's more than enough you ain't gotta
do no more than that but yeah go salute
that i already got the plug i got you
get you i got that advance for you i got
that in fact anyway so we're done
plugging we're done doing all our
promotions we're getting this two more
rooms
we got gerald back shout out to you sir
oh hell the ilp salute the lords happy
dads they realm to you as well my
brother thank you we got jd gamer five
dollar super chat giving a shout out to
the lords hit that like button thank you
sir
no doubt so we all caught up all good
yeah we're good he said the hustle is
real even though the lord's dead yeah
no don't judge me general vaccine all
right listen all right cool so look
that's what we're here for man this is
our kind of like traditional thing that
we do
the xbox showcase aftermath right so now
that we've had a chance to kind of
settle in we've had the announcements we
had the emotionality of it all the
things that took place i want everyone's
feeling on that we'll start with red
again we're going to start but just to
showcase itself we'll separate the
extended showcase but just to showcase
now that you've had time
for it to settle they ran outdoor has
anything changed how are we feeling
about it
yeah you know i mean nothing's really
changed um i thought it was a solid show
i didn't think it was like a great show
or a bad show i'd give it like um you
know
solid b maybe maybe more towards
floating like b minus okay
um
i i i did i did feel like um
[Music]
there's definitely a lot of games
that are coming out for xbox that uh i
really want to play and it definitely
highlighted
uh a lot of those during this this
format like high in life from the rick
and rick and morty people
very unique like we even got the info
that that might have been a stadia game
right well it was that there was that
and what was the other game that wasn't
again corey the quarry yeah oh i never
knew that yeah
i think the info dropped on friday
uh there was like that benedict's fox
game that looked really cool
um and a few others like just off the
top my head i i can't remember them all
but
uh i think the big takeaway for a lot of
people at least like when i talk to
people or when i read the chat of xbox 2
or the comments sections everywhere is
like a lot of people were thrown off by
the 12-month thing
right a lot of people
had expectations of seeing certain games
right and
you know i mean like i made my
prediction video based around the fact
that i thought hey this is going to be
your typical microsoft show
they're going to show stuff coming soon
but then they're gonna announce things
coming in a couple years well we were
all wrong
so microsoft decided not to do that and
i think that really kind of
screwed with people's uh expectations
because
everybody's like all right well val's
going to be there and contraband and
hellblade 2
and all these other games that might be
coming soon
and then as soon as sarah was like no
we're doing something we've never done
before first time ever
this is all the stuff you're playing in
the next year
and everybody was like oh
oh well i guess i guess we're not going
to see some of the stuff which is in
stark contrast to how most
of these shows are like
we've been basically kind of been
like i don't know i'm not gonna say
force fed but we've been we've been
trained to expect more to expect yeah
cgi announcements of games three years
out and for a lot of people
that is what e3 is all about it's about
getting hyped for games that are years
away right so when you finally
like get into this thing where it's just
a year
i don't know people it's such a new
concept that a lot of people didn't
really know uh how to react or were
disappointed that we weren't going to
see uh certain games like xbox is kind
of in like
you know
damned if you do damned if you don't
situation right like
it's like okay here's all the stuff
coming but then they are also the ones
that announced two years ago here's
about here's fable here's state of the
k3 here's perfect dark and people want
to see updates on those titles
right and you're not getting it so
there's that frustration disappointment
from you know maybe wanting to see that
that permeated through
uh
the showcase but
i appreciated the format
i really
way more enjoyed to look at gameplay
than i do typically at a cgi trailer um
and i i really think
this showcase would have been better
served if they did it next year
and they did
i agree
mainly because break it down one
to me the reason i gave it like a solid
score like a b with maybe floating to a
b minus
was i felt like this year's show was
too much or it felt like a repeat of
last year's
okay right so you're going you're going
into this year's show and you're like
okay what's going to be new and then
they just hit you with star field again
and red fall again right and instead of
forza rising you get fours of
motorsports
and we get another look at elder scrolls
online and fallout 76 so there was a
part of the show to lease to me that was
just
last year's show just done again but
longer
and you know but i do appreciate
immensely the longer look at starfield
to finally see what that's like
what redfield is redfall is all about
right
i just feel like they should have done a
regular show this year and then done the
12 months next year because
there's a lot more titles uh activision
most likely would have been acquired by
then
uh i don't know the studios i want to
actually interrupt two things one when
you say you wanted that next year the
formatting show because it almost like
you didn't want to see the
stuff in a red rifle
i like the format of the show i just
i just didn't
i i felt like there wasn't enough yeah
new announcements
game studios which is why i'm saying
this show would have worked better next
year oh you mean the format right format
will work next year guys
because there would have been a whole
bunch of new stuff got you got you uh
whereas this year's show was just a
bunch of stuff you were already new
totally understandable last year let me
back up one last question and i'll stop
interrupting you um so then now do you
think
it was a bad precedent for sarah to come
out
during the show
right like what my question to you is
are you are you upset that kind of like
maybe they shouldn't have done that
announcement during the show versus like
an aaron greenberg tweet prior to the
show saying hey these are the 12 months
like
is that part of the source of your uh
frustration
i'm not i'm not frustrated by it i'm
just looking at it being like oh this
would have worked better next year but
um i'm more kind of thinking about it
from people in the communities like
perspective i
xbox is usually pretty good at um
qualifying or setting expectations right
on what shows are going to be about
right
they didn't do this this year and a lot
of people were using that as
well
you know wolfenstein trees coming and
everybody was all getting hyped for all
these certain things that potentially
might happen because aaron greenberg
didn't set anybody's expectations right
i do feel that if
they had said
a week out if aaron greenberg come out
and said hey just want to give everybody
an update
uh the games that are going to be shown
are just going to be strictly uh the
games that are coming out in the next
year so from june to june okay
i think
people
i think people just like with the star
field and red fall delay you let like
people
uh get out their emotions there because
i think me and you had this conversation
you asked me what would have been better
if they announced the delays of
starfield and redfall a month before or
announced them during the conference
remember yes
and we both were like well obviously
announcing it before because the whole
talk of the conference would have been
those delays
i do think people would have would have
appreciated it more but i mean maybe i'm
in the minority in this one because
looking at uh reactions online looking
at like jeff keeley's poll yeah
it was like you know mostly a's and b's
it was like 75 percent a and b so it
feels like maybe microsoft accomplished
what they set out to do like
the showcase
wasn't so much
about uh
selling xbox game studios it was really
just about selling game pass
about like here's the service that is
coming out and here's all these games
that you can enjoy
in the next year like look at everything
here
and while hardcore guys might have been
like
man i really wanted to see my favorite
game and i didn't see it
somebody else might watching it might
appreciate the diversity and found at
least a game that they would hang their
hat on and be like that's cool these are
all the things coming
um i thought this show was really good
so
i guess it really depends on
what you wanted out of the show
realistically uh i know some people were
were frustrated uh king you know uh
yeah i heard i heard what he said king
you know king king didn't care for it so
much you know i've heard of the people
didn't care for it so much which is fine
everybody's you know voiced their
opinions and everyone you know everybody
can have their thoughts about about
those things but
um
yeah i just um i thought i just felt it
was just a solid show i i did feel last
year's was
a lot better last year's i felt was one
of their best shows ever
and i i think this one was
i don't know like it didn't uh it didn't
hit as
as
uh high it didn't hit as high as a note
for me as i thought maybe it could have
got you uh but i feel like
next year
with this format of 12 months
uh seeing about gameplay and contraband
gameplay and all that sort of stuff i
think it would people would be like oh
okay
this is what's coming so okay then i
mean those are those are pretty much my
thoughts guys
man i feel your friends get my man
boxing berg i i need the proper
pronunciation of wolfenstein i had that
correct we have we have germany
thank you
can you say can you say terror billy for
me please
terror billy
[Laughter]
salute the boxing burger man so what's
up with the world of the game how are we
feeling now that you don't show
got a chance to settle in we look at it
now has anything changed has your score
remained the same has it going up like
what are you feeling about the xbox
showcase
oh it has pretty much remained the same
um my initial thought thoughts were
really mixed there were some parts of
the show that i absolutely loved um like
that they focused on gameplay i've been
saying that for a long time i want them
to show more gameplay less cgi they did
a fantastic job with that
and i mean some of the games that they
have shown look incredible of course the
big ones like staff at red falls
thoughts are awesome diablo showed
really well so
it's it's really not about
what they showed in the show that was my
problem i have two issues with the show
the first is
that xbox has
arguably their
worst 20 worst year ever 2022 is pretty
much empty from a first party
perspective
um i mean i'm not counting my dimension
is coming out
[Laughter]
yeah
you know whatever you do
are we applying triple a first party
triple a okay
even if we count pentament yeah it is it
is really um empty and i actually have a
problem with that um i think like
we all agreed that probably 2017 was
considered the low point for xbox so far
but at least in that year they had a
console launch which was pretty exciting
with the xbox one x yeah and then they
bought all these studios in 2018 19 and
now we're here four years later
and with 23 studios you can't put out a
single game i found that
very irritating and
um
[Music]
i've heard so many times people say that
yeah well game pass is going to keep me
busy
and for me at least i personally have to
say is it really from what they have
shown
that in the showcase i have like three
four game pass games that come this year
there are tons of stuff tons of games
coming next year that i'm super excited
about but this year it's blake tale it's
high on life
then it is dark tide which wasn't even
at the show yeah and maybe i'm missing
one yeah so
um i'm not sure if that is going to keep
me busy at least from what they have
announced today persona is not doing
anything for me that's that's just not
let's not show up there yeah okay um
so yeah what is there in 2022 and i am
actually disappointed in xbox that this
has happened um so
that is of course a big minus for me
there
um
and the second thing is with the 12
12 month format um i get what rand is
saying and i agree that this format
probably would have worked a lot better
next year
um but in a year where you really don't
have any games and the exciting stuff is
really coming at the end of the 12-month
period that you have showcased
yeah i'm not sure if this is really what
you should have done
and not give us a little bit of an
update on the roadmap that is coming a
little bit further down the line um and
i find it hard to believe that of out of
all these studios you couldn't show
either an update or at least one or two
um surprise announcements like a the
compulsion game in excel i don't know i
was hoping for something yeah yeah um
[Music]
let me interrupt you one quick thing
because you're making some interesting
points um what i want to ask you box
burger do you think the choice they made
to do the 12 months which i can tell you
a little frustrated with and a lot of
people are frustrated a lot of people
agree with you you know do you think
that's indicative
that they that things are not ready or
there is a problem because sometimes you
you hear that discussion i just want to
know what your mindset was on that
yeah well
um
it is speak your truth
yeah i'm i i will speak my truth uh i
lost so many followers you have no idea
oh you were spicy i missed this let me
hear it let's go but i
uh yeah i i do think who do you want to
hold responsible for not having a single
first party major release in
15 months at least like from november 21
to at least february 23
no releases who do you hold responsible
of course it is a management problem
and i think
i think um
it is
if you bring up the point about
management problem the question really
is i'm not saying that
but necessarily the wrong people are in
the wrong
position to make the decisions but the
way how the company acts with
their
hands-off mentality is a problem we have
seen it with three for three um we have
heard other studios having issues like
um the initiative um we have heard um
undead labs and so on i'm not really
sure if that is actually the right um
approach the right
approach yeah um
[Music]
because yeah the pandemic is a real
thing and i know a lot of people don't
want to hear the excuse it is an issue
but
it is also an issue that is ongoing for
two years plus now and other companies
have adjusted to that and they have
found their ways of working around that
and in fairness boxing burger a lot of
the major a lot of
platform holders like literally every
major game on like sony's platform and
nintendo with breath of the wild too has
been delayed just in fairness and i just
wanted to be clear but i understand
like you said every major publisher has
delayed almost every game at least for a
bit um but that still me uh leaves us
xbox gamers with a um with a 15 month
um dry streak yeah and yeah um you don't
have that on any other platform and
um
so yeah i think i think um xbox really
um has an issue there and um
yeah it's gonna
eventually all these games have to come
out and 23 it looks like 23 is finally
the the year i mean at least from what
we already know look at first half with
the diablo four a thoughts of red fall
or star field it's it's an insane first
half of the year
um
i just do hope that these these holes
these these dry streaks won't come up in
a 24-25 again because of some
weird things
but yeah as of right now
for the showcase um it was a good show
it was really not that there that they
showed the wrong stuff
per se uh i just thought that they
missed a couple of things leave the
fallout 76
cgi trailer there
a cgi trailer for a compulsion game then
you still have the gameplay and you give
us a little bit of an outlook of the for
the roadmap but it's coming a little bit
later i get it you wanted you wanted an
hour of sea of thieves that's what you
wanted
but i waited
a lot of people had issues with seeing
fallout 76 eso
sea of thieves you know content at the
big show so to speak as opposed to the
extended showcase so that that sentiment
has been out there so i i have heard
that i i hate you possibly i hear you
man talking that talk a little doubt
i'll let you finish your thought and
then i'll pass it off to adam
um no i'm pretty much done i just want
to say one thing about the extended
showcase hold on what's the collector
because we got that that's what next we
go
okay so we're talking about this yeah
which is just the main one just the main
one then
i think i'm pretty much done so i ended
up giving this a seven out of ten
it's really not that that there were too
many games that i'm looking forward to
in that show that i say it's a bad show
that wasn't a bad show i just thought
that they missed uh two things and that
is like i said the the
games we have in 22 and a little bit of
excitement with a surprise announcement
so no one would say let me let me
address something yeah real quick shout
out to boozy buzzy boozy he's like no
lessons learned in the xbox community
stop hyping the games for the future
discuss games we can play for
all right look i i understand you're
sentiment but here's the thing you know
at the end of the day as a showcase part
of it it's called the prediction series
what we predict to happen and what we
may want to happen so people have very
levels of excitement in what they have
now what i do agree with them some
people get to put themselves on these
predictions and then they don't happen
and they blame x
you know saying but it did not happen
but to tell people to stop being excited
or to stop making predictions i can't i
can't roll with that one bro but anyway
moving on lord addict how are we doing
are we awake how's it going
he's in the bushes still
can you not hear me you're alone really
low really low
is that better a little bit yeah what's
that man yes i just don't feel good yeah
you know if you guys are feeling good
bro like i said jazz wasn't feeling good
today i'm just gonna sit in bed i might
as well at least do something okay well
we glad to have you i didn't know what
was going on but good man like just
again the um the regular showcase itself
you know that the dust is settled like
how are you how are you feeling about
has anything changed or has it remained
the same
i i feel like the show is underwhelming
for me now
i think the biggest reason it is is
because they have
set weird expectations in previous years
like one year they'll show everything
one year now they're doing 12 months so
i feel like
through out the next couple years last
couple years we've seen stuff like
avowed fable
you know perfect dart so people expected
yo we saw that years ago we're expecting
actual updates on these games now and
then sarah ball pops up on stage and say
we showed you 12 months and i'm like
what
it's like i'm not saying that like this
isn't the way they should because
i'd actually
prefer this
over show me games as years
apart but
i prefer this after you've got those
games out so we're not expecting those
games to show up okay
um so you know i actually i think they
need to do
a little bit of both i think the best
thing that they need to do is like yeah
i think they said it was 90 minutes so
i would say
six
70 minutes of this is the 12-month thing
and that lasts like 20 25 of the show is
we've showed you what's going to be here
soon this is what is going to be out
here
farther than 12 months okay i feel like
when you take when you
dig themselves in a box like they did
and one they didn't set expectations
correctly i mean
i've literally seen aaron greenberg come
out
and address people if if there's like
one or two rumors going out there right
he didn't do none of that so you know i
think that's part of the issues too it's
like we're used to getting the aaron
greenberg tweet beforehand as opposed to
sarah coming on the scene
things should have been said beforehand
or gotcha okay
i i don't i i just it's
it's just weird the microsoft that we
deal with
why they didn't do that like i've
i'm i'm just i i wouldn't want to say
that like
they intentionally bamboozled us like
they they wanted us to be excited but
it's just like every year
this is the king of the
set your expectations correct
and now randomly this year it's like
they forgot that memo yeah and it's just
like look
it is what it is like maybe they didn't
want to say the 12-month thing i don't
know uh you know but then again it's
it's like ryan said uh jeff keeley had a
poll that was over a hundred thousand
people voted the majority of them voted
hey so
you know is the hardcore disconnected
are we as the hardcore
disconnected
from
the casual and the masses and the masses
let's just say obviously his poll will
represent everyone but he has a big
following right so is that indicative
that gaming has passed us hardcore gave
us by and it's a new era because they
love the show there's gays and bees
yeah yeah
it was colton ran three tweeties so all
they thought oh so so cold and red are
responsible for blowing up jeff
teagley's phone
retweeted sir got it
you
you're rigging the pole the pole there
is it is it possible to rig jeff
keeley's poll you know like i feel like
he's mostly filed by playstation guys
you know like that's his audience
so are you saying that maybe because you
know playstation other platform holders
that maybe are not in the xbox ecosystem
really like the show as opposed to the
hardcore xbox okay i did i did a poll
let's go
you would i have thirty four thousand
followers
uh
yeah and you would figure most of my
followers are um
xbox you know like not necessarily
always hardcore but xbox focused yeah
and i had like six thousand votes and
mine was
very very strongly a b
okay like overwhelmingly so would be and
then jeff's was mostly an a so maybe
there was a disconnect between the
hardcore xbox guys who have it in their
heads you know fables dancing around
their heads and perfect arcs
you know they're they're thinking of
like how xbox has always done their
shows
and they're thinking like we're gonna
get all these new announcements right
wolfenstein three we're gonna get
banjo-kazooie we're gonna get the gears
collection
and we're getting all these
announcements and that none of it
actually shows up and like boxing burger
said and i totally agree with them uh
2022 worst year in xbox first party
history like 100 percent
now i've heard colts say that he thinks
the reason they did the 12 months was to
essentially hide the fact that they have
nothing from first party this year right
i i agree with them um they deliberately
did that for a reason you know as far as
to be honest with you rant i wouldn't be
surprised next year if they abandoned
the 12-month thing you think it was a
tribulation
let me ask oh yeah because y'all cook it
y'all cook it
do y'all think i've always wanted to ask
ran this on all of y'all this like do
you think
let's be i hate to throw blame and throw
the guard howard under the butt but do
you think the star field and and red
four situation the double whammy of two
triple a first party games
being delayed for the most part can we
assume potentially last minute because
microsoft was promoting these games
assuming that they were coming out do
you think that forced the like the game
the audible so to speak like the
football play at the at the last minute
to say well these are here how do we
adapt and maybe now let's do this
12-month format because my question is
if those games wasn't delayed do we get
a 12-month format
that's an interesting question and i
don't know the answer to that because
once those games got delayed you know
you knew xbox was light and the only
hope was forza motorsport which then
was next year anyways
uh that's an interesting question like
they're maybe they're maybe in another
parallel world another multiverse we
would know the answer to that
if starfield and redfall were this year
i think it's i think it's
we can't
i i come into june with an expectation
of a certain type of show
and what they've shown me is that it
just it it pivots according to the
situation at hand and we can no longer
expect that big bombastic sort of
show in in june if that's not what they
have to show us i think it's going to be
fluid every single year so
the expectation of what an e3s show is
to me is changes on a year-to-year basis
i completely agree with rand that if
they had decided to
do the 12-month format next year it
looks amazing because we probably do see
about we probably do see hellblade right
we maybe they push something a little
further out and show us that
i think that
having expectations about what type of
stuff you're going to see forget about
specific things right well what type of
stuff you're going to see at an e3s or
e3 window type show i don't i think it's
a fool's errand from from here on out i
think just because they're going to
pivot according to what they have
and
that's it i mean you do you do think
based on that statement you do think
that change and they pivoted yeah i
don't know how early they pivoted they
might have pivoted the moment they just
they decided they needed to delay star
field and red fall and that that you
know that was the plan going into
setting up the show i don't know that it
was a last minute thing per se
um but i think they think that they um
they did the 12-month thing because they
had started on the right fall
oh
so yeah because if starfield and red
falk do come out in that window then
then rand's point is super valid and
this 12 month thing looks extra great
because it's like wow we have these two
humongous games in this 12 month period
and whatever and
but
i don't know because if you look look at
it they opened with one and closed with
one right you turn your mic up a little
bit at it a little low okay
yeah i mean i didn't
get rid of i was gonna
i was gonna say
i think it would look
kind of spooky
if they go back to regular format next
year
i honestly do like if
if because then that would because
you look at like their their metrics of
people liking this show right we already
know we discussed that jeff keeley
uh
i think
i i think it probably tells you that
better internally really well right uh
people at fan fest were sort of saying
those things like
so like you have this situation they've
never done it before
and is it the cover
for xbox's lackluster first party this
year right maybe maybe not we don't know
the answer because they dropped the bomb
on them last minute ready the picture is
true
however cog
next year if you go to e3
and okay
if you if you're looking at it and like
boxing burgers said the game's gonna
come out at some point all these titles
are essentially going to have to like
reach their apex and be like we're
finished and you have all these other
games coming and then if you decide
not to do 12 months ago
it would make the previous show be like
well
why'd you decide to do it then but not
decide to do it moving forward
so to me it would it would it would it
would it would be spooky and i'd be like
okay they did it last year because they
just simply like like saab said like
they they just changed things because of
the cards they were dealt
and now that they actually have a whole
bunch of stuff coming they're gonna they
feel fine about
about uh changing it up again but i
think this also speaks to the idea of
xbox needs to do more shows
you can't just
yeah look at next year right look at
look at early next year
you have red fallen starfield right you
have fours of motorsport three oh yeah
four's a motorsport eight uh you have
minecraft legends
yeah you have uh error history untold
uh if the deal goes through you'll have
diablo four
and ghostwire tokyo if it comes out
after one year thing that'd be seven
games from box first party
in a six month window
that is a lot of content yes and a lot
of those games like diablo 4 starfield
and red fall and forza motorsport are
big enough where they deserve
their own sort of
show
yeah and then if you go into the end of
the year and you're looking like okay
avowed hellblade two contraband
coalition coalition's new ip yeah uh in
exile like you you start like okay you
can't no longer rely on just one day in
june you gotta you gotta do more stuff i
think they absolutely need state of play
style presentations for each one of
those big games for sure and the
assumption that the activision blizzard
deal will close right which is more
content in fusion so to speak to talk
about but continue right that's a great
point
well yeah so like i said
oh somebody somebody's a cop yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna mute you know
[Laughter]
so i guess we'll find out i mean we know
they're hiring for people for these sort
of events and
maybe there is an exo 2022 maybe they
bring that back i mean i think them
doing fan fest again
paints a good picture for them
potentially bringing back like a fan
fest show
uh at the end of the year and then maybe
you can do i don't know what's coming in
the next year from them
i just kind of i'm just kind of
interested in seeing how they how they
move this going forward because i do
appreciate gameplay over cgi
i don't need
cgi announcements of games three years
out
um
so yeah i'm wondering how oxford box is
going to do this because the beginning
of the show and the end of the show were
great yes
it was the middle con the middle of the
show was just kind of
it had its ups and downs it had its
moments where it was completely boring
and then it brought it back up but then
it went back down yeah and it's nice to
see
that phil like all phil's trips to japan
paid off fruit i know people were saying
oh he just goes over there there's
nothing to it he goes over there he gets
stuff done you get kojima signed
making a game like he said he always
wanted to make that's a big thing you're
bringing back team ninja to the platform
after they've skipped for a bit like
those are are big moves and then you get
atlas to finally support your platform
taking something
right
already i had it all lined up for
someone
those are big things
you know phil's trips to japan
they're they're bearing fruit
um it's just um i think
go ahead go ahead
i was gonna say i think the biggest
issue ryan
is you know
clearly this event was used as a
as a value point on game pass all these
games coming to game pass in 12 months
but to me
microsoft the game pass isn't the issue
the issue is people are like what are
your studios doing they've been doing
they've been around since 2017-18 and we
haven't seen the majority of them right
and i think that was
that was what they should have tackled
it's just
now
that that persona ain't went nowhere you
know what i'm saying that people if
anything they're even worse than they
were last time
so it's just like look like
no it's like i said no one is is denying
how
much of a
value game pass
you know you can put all those games on
there and they're gonna it's gonna look
very appealing but then people are gonna
be like that's cute but what's the stuff
that i bought your xbox for right
so you think so you think
they should have structured the show
more to
uh address the criticism
that people have about what boxing
burger brought up earlier about the
mismanagement of studios and address
that more
it's not even
management
it's not even about the mismanagement i
think people just
like look
people exp like go look at all all the
prediction shows look most of us i
thought we had realistic expectations
and we we didn't some has pie for this
guy
we don't expect to see around boom we
don't expect
we don't expect to see perfect
i thought we was coming into this with
realistic
and that's what boozy did whatever his
name um had said like we just
i thought we was us was was realistic
you know what i'm saying obviously
you're going to have like i said the
bones of the kids shout out we love them
not you know they're going to go for it
right but they people can't impose those
two as everyone in the xbox community
felt that way i personally felt i felt
boxing you addicts of ran
all of us i felt were in the realm of
reason of what realistically happened
nobody could predict that microsoft was
going to do something they've never done
before right that's true and if they
told us that if they had told us that i
would have changed my predictions and i
would i mean
at the bare minimum ran they should have
told us that at least a valve wasn't
going to be there at the bare minimum
like with there was people hyping up
without being at the show for like a
month and a half before this you wanted
them to come out and say it's that yes
they've done that before like saying i
think the president when they've said
hey we're not going to show you this
game they've done they've done that with
halo before that they've done that in
the past before saying a certain game's
not going to be there they've done that
with fable a couple times
fable's not going to be at this show
they've done that aaron greenberg is the
king that that's that's that's why i
feel like
they didn't i don't know why they didn't
do it this time it was literally
yeah it was sort of the mo after the
third party gameplay kind of fiasco if
you want to call it that one he was like
oh we're gonna have game play at the you
know and then they still like you know
but specifically with greenberg's making
a tweet saying this game ain't gonna be
there
i don't i'm just saying maybe correct me
if i put it on twitter before i remember
i know for i remember for a fact he did
it with uh fable
once i think it was last year he did it
on fable
i mean i think it isn't uh out of the
or our expectations aren't set too high
if we go into an xbox show and we expect
xbox games to be
and i think
you have to say like that
is that wrong
are you implying that you are not a fan
of the riot games announcement are you
implying that the pc the riot thing is
is a big thing league of legends isn't
for me but this is at least a big thing
but if you look at the whole show
what i it was a bethesda show
you could say
at least they had had a few games and we
had one xbox game there and that's about
it um so i don't think that the
expectations were
some expectations were too high right
exactly
are you saying are you saying pentament
isn't an xbox game yeah
yeah well uh no i can't argue against
that
but you know what it is like
i mean they left it out there where it's
like yeah when you look at the the big
things that we're showing you ground
games
uh they're not they're not they're not
what you would consider of
homegrown
grounded is that home
are we shaming
indian
it's
as opposed to the main course
it is one of those things and until
a studio that they sort of built from
the ground up or evolved from something
small
we have caveats so that's always going
to be i'm not i'm not saying that i have
those caveats oh those characters okay
that's all that's all this is what you
what you've heard conversation around
xbox always involves those caveats
that's for sure i think you know this is
true i'll mess with you yeah
can i give you a story yes so the
ultimate thing right let's go i argued
with jazz for a long time about
he was like i'm going to leak this
pentameter game because i think it's
going to leak and i was like
are you sure
because
i think people because i had seen a
screenshot from the game
right he showed me the screenshot how it
looked i knew 100 how it looked and i
told him
okay
i don't
i don't i don't think people like
you could you could you could leak it
because jez will normally get stuff and
then he'll he thinks somebody's else is
about to leak it like a jeff grubb
or maybe a tom henderson or somebody
right
um and if he has the info he'll be like
well i need i need to put this out
because i gotta you know i gotta write
for windows central for a living so i
gotta do stuff so he had the he had the
pentament info i'd sing the screenshot
that he showed me
and i was like if you leak this
with the name
and then say it's disciple and elysium
inspired and all this stuff this is
going to set a mental picture for people
and when it's shown nobody is going to
expect the art style that it's going to
have so i i kind of went back and forth
with them because
i'm good rand okay
i'm like the angel on jez's shoulder
listen don't do it maybe you shouldn't
leak this stuff
uh you should hold something but you
know he's he's got like the devil on his
i'm shoulder like you know what maybe
not jeff grubb is outside i i got a
defender gotta defend her boy just cuz
you know he don't do it first jeff go do
it he just did it and the whole time i'm
sitting there like man this game when
they revealed this game
people have this
thought of what it's going to look like
nobody has a clue
and uh
yeah like i remember hearing mag's
reaction on it on boom show
i think people weren't prepared for that
art style
you know so that this is fair this is
fair and i understand exactly where
you're coming from with that and um it
is interesting i'll jump in because i
ever get a chance to go but um
look with the pentameter thing i wish i
got a comment because i i'm so team
obsidian i am so t-shirt bro i got
obsidian i wear a i love upset i think
of city this number one xbox game studio
signing and they still are in my opinion
until but there's a drop when they drop
and prove that they're the you know
bethesda that we know right
but for me
i built my i'm guilty i built the
expectation of what i thought pentamete
would be
more in a double a space and when i saw
the art style if i would have saw it
yeah it probably threw me off because i
was a little disappointed because i
built my own expectation up now there's
no doubt in my mind though josh sawyer
the narrative the game itself is
probably going to be a fantastic game
once i played it's the type of game
right so
i know i had to check once i checked
myself i think it's going to be
fantastic
and i like the actual time period so let
me be clear it was just
germany or so
there we go you already know germany in
the building i think the biggest issue
that i had with that game is how i had
with grounded yeah it doesn't look like
the reason i love right
and and here's the thing and this is
where solve is right with the goal post
moving and the you know you know people
expectation from xbox is that
the hardcore are gonna look at that and
be like or say like yo that ain't it
right but here's the thing that's
interesting to me because now it doesn't
settle and i had a good talk with manny
on the final duke about this right and
he he asked me a great question he's
like
do you think this is going to be one of
those shows that a year from now
we look at differently
and i think the answer is yes and the
reason why i say that is this
we the hardcore
we know what we love we all have our
biases we all have our favorites right
but to me the approach that they have
shown with this take the 12-month part
out of it but the the approach that
they've shown is that
xbox is gonna have a diverse lineup with
a variety of games for everyone that
seems to be the mantra going forward and
to me that aligns with their overall
vision which is game pass now i'm still
standing on my square for me it was a
seven out of ten it wasn't i wasn't mind
blown you know what i'm saying there
were some things that was definitely for
me the end of the show was spoke to my
soul and i'm with ran like i don't think
they get enough credit for the japanese
commitment like people said that cannot
be done you know what i'm saying the
last time i even seen any japanese
presence on any level was during the
peter moore area
yeah which is my guy with the 360 lost
odyssey or that that was eight years ago
the reaction was so bad for having
kojima and persona on that alex is able
to make two or three videos shout out to
oh no
but here's the thing because the thing
is
my thing is those games can't miss the
platform right if you're truly trying to
be game passing everywhere and every
device there's a region that you're
lacking and to me every this i look at
it every genre
in that show was represented minus
fighting
fighting i'm going to be on xbox for
y'all if y'all don't get this fighting
game situation together i'm gonna be on
you i'm always gonna tell you what you
need to hear what the fighting is what's
going on killer instinct what's going on
that's why i'm always team netherrealm
or whoever the fighting game studio to
make happen you know so but other than
that if you look at it objectively you
in my opinion you can't walk away from
that show and say there was nothing for
me right there was something for you now
the question that's the only player head
to head fighters exactly exactly yes the
only person that should be yelling is
the fgc if the fgc watched that show and
like your family had not one fighter bro
i'm out xbox but you if you're objective
and honest you can't say there's not at
least one game that is interesting to
you so the point becomes now i get the
overall show if you watch it from an
overall perspective and you got your one
to two one to three games that you like
but she's like damn i really feel
nothing else i feel that's fair right i
feel that fair criticism there but i
think that look
again i go back to the japanese stuff
the persona like ran said with atlas
kojima making the game for them i think
is huge i thought red fall looked good
i i was actually i was more impressed
with the showing of red fall
red fall really showed me something i i
i came in with very low expectation for
that you think that's what it was like i
kind of had it like a semi expectation
or what to
do i knew why i was going to say a star
photo to a point i didn't know what the
game was going to look like i had no
idea what rainfall was going to be and i
can always just say by the end of that
you could go back and watch our reaction
like the whole time i'm like yo this
actually looks good like this no apps
you know red 4 really impressed me you
know what i'm saying so you got that you
know star feel i get it is it fair to
criticize certain things about it
absolutely but i'm not you know why i'm
not with ram i'm not with these bad
faith comparisons
what type of bad faith can this bad face
comparatively you know what it is people
just to me expose themselves for not
playing but that's the games oh because
if you're gonna sit there and say that
this is a one-to-one this all this is is
no man's sky you don't play bethesda
games you don't know about the systems
you don't know about true rpg mechanics
npc's decision making crime justice
system how one effect thing you do
affects the entire world the reactions
the ai you you don't understand that and
then the fact that this game's scope is
so large because you not not only do you
have the true rpg then you have ship
what you call it um fighting dog
fighting fighting
in space going to planets you know i'm
saying a narrative based story so
if you're gonna tell me and i play no
man's sky so if you're gonna tell me
that it's like
you have an agenda to because you don't
like the game for whatever reason it's
okay to be critical of the game but to
say that's a one-to-one that is a bad
faith comparison i i can't i can't
because you just expose you don't play
both you don't play either games you
don't play the best guy you don't play
which i mean one is the survival game
and the other one is the
narrative-driven
exactly yeah exactly now where i'm with
boxing burger where i'm with you bro is
that to me and i'm going this is my
assumption
because of the first party situation i
really felt they got thrown a curveball
but then i'm blaming i'm blaming
bethesda i'm sorry i think that they had
every intention for red four starfield
to be there
they get the memo last minute and i'm
gonna say i don't have no inside
information i felt i felt phil died on
this sword for that because remember
phil got it i mean
regardless what was going to happen it
is his
regardless nobody want to hear what he
was going to get in that sword
nobody want to hear it but
in his defense
todd put his chest out talking 11 11 a
year early
yeah but my thing is you trust in your
story now this this comes down to
approach right is the hands-on approach
good or not this is maybe a situation
where maybe it didn't work out in their
favor maybe you were supposed to check
their build you know i said maybe you
were supposed to see a little bit more
maybe he put too much trust in them and
then they they you know it didn't happen
and now let's be honest the right
decision was made
delay the game right don't put this
thing out and you have a situation you
know what i'm saying so my thing is i
don't i want the best for stuff i want
to i think it the scope is tremendous so
the last thing i'll say about the
management thing because i know where
you're going boxing burger i just want
to be fair because i do want i think
what you're saying is fair i don't think
nothing's wrong what you're saying i
just think that i want to show the other
side too i don't know if anybody got a
chance to watch um that ign article that
they did with obsidian
and it was yes it was it really spoke a
lot to me about their decision to join
xbox game studio they literally said one
specifically because of phil two when
they looked at the mon yang situation
they looked at the hands off the mix man
they're not with the tendrils in yo you
gonna do this are you going to put
connect in the game are you going to
you know who else they brought up that i
was surprised
he brought up matt booty yeah
he already knew who matt booty was they
were already friends right
because he said in that he didn't really
know phil at that time exactly and to me
for the people who like yo why i be
cabin for
literally studios would not exist and
sign with xbox because of him we've even
heard rand correct me if i'm wrong the
owner of bethesda who sadly passed away
you know and todd our good friend but
part of the reason the deal was done was
the expectation that phil is going to be
there for a couple of years
so is it he yeah solely responsible for
them getting uh mojang too right so so
all this mismanagement talk and
hands-off talk i get it it may not work
for every single studio but there are
examples of studios that love this
approach and wouldn't have signed with
xbox if this approach didn't exist so we
all i'm just saying for balance
i love that that's because i didn't know
it was uh ferguson marquardt the ceo of
obsidian yeah
obsidian that to me is a big deal and it
gave me insight on something i didn't
know but look last point i'll say is um
as far as me where i look at it i get it
to seven personally for me they've given
me things in this showcase with the
japanese game the sega franchise and all
these things that i'm like okay the
future is bright but for this year
you're in a pickle you know what i'm
saying and you you kind of had to that's
how you got to see your thieves in the
eso and you gotta do what you gotta do
but that that's what i got on this i
wanna quickly transition into the wait
hold on you just forgot
we only just did an interview together
this week
we builded our trust back
i mean
you can't really you can't really blame
blame cog though you can't really see
you without your knees
shout out i gotta say that real quick
that was that it touched the soul but it
was actually the khaji what they wanted
kajima because i've been predicting it
for so long and i'm like i'll be hitting
up jeff i'm like bro you let her intent
right it's still on nothing
so i'm like all right he's got it so
when kojima came and i know people like
yo he didn't know to give me i get it he
did the same thing with playstation the
first time somebody he was announced but
five years later that's right
shut up so it's symbolic and to me it
represents a new day a new direction
they are committed but anyway enough of
me soft get your balls off i apologize
no listen you guys pretty much touched
on everything like i really do think
that for me and i'm probably gonna
forget this by the time we get to next
year's showcase right but for me i just
think moving forward
i'm going to remove expectations of what
type of stuff we're going to see in
terms of how far out
how many big surprises i think it's just
going to be fluid depending on the
situation of of of where they're at um
where the competition is at right and i
think another thing we didn't touch upon
is the fact that i really do think when
it comes to
determining what you're showing at a
showcase
if there's a big in-person event where
you know there's going to be people in
an auditorium i think the impetus to
sort of show
more sort of bombastic stuff is sort of
there as opposed to everybody's at home
you can get over i think as a business
decision
it's something that can easily be made
like hey everybody's at home we're not
although they did have an in-person
thing this year kind of like a fan fest
thing it was not the same as filling up
the microsoft theater with you know
however many people and and showing out
so i do think that's going to have some
sort of some sort of uh
determination as to what they do
but
you know
i was hard on the show i was very hard
on this yeah you were there you went in
on star field
yeah yeah but again i wasn't the no
man's sky guy that's true you didn't do
that
i'm with you on presentation and
we weren't going to compare no man's sky
to yeah
now we are yeah yeah i definitely wasn't
that dude yeah he wasn't that oh
but
and i think part of it was like me like
looking back and forth at super chats
like copy pasting super chats and i
wasn't like listening to everything i
was just sort of looking at everything
but when i i went back okay at the
rundown right i completely agree about
the lull in the middle i think the lull
in the middle is just and king touched
upon this that it is that thing of like
you if you had reordered certain stuff
and make sure your highs and lows and
your crescendos were
were certain of a certain height then i
just think it would have played out
better all the way across it when you
put a bunch of games in the middle that
are
your ears your eso's and your things
like that where people kind of
like king said tuesday energy didn't
feel like it really belonged in this big
showcase
i just think it brought down the mood
and it took a little bit to sort of ramp
back up
um the beginning was great the end was
great but then looking at everything
that they did show in the middle when
you think about
you know when you think about how these
games looks when you think about like a
high on life when you think about much
like you know the the japanese sort of
in
you know the kojima the getting the
persona games on there i think the riot
thing is huge
people sleeping people sleeping here
this is so huge for game pass because
one of the things that i missed
why during the show was the fact that
once these games come into game pass
everything that you would pay for
piecemeal on the pc side is included in
this game pass package so you come in
and you have all those heroes unlocked
already right
yeah we're we're talking about literally
the biggest games
the biggest the biggest the biggest
especially
that's a beast of its own
and we'll talk about another big game
that uh they announced in the extended
in a second but again
very smart moves to improve the pc game
pass aspect of game pass right um but
then again you look at everything else
like a plague's tale forced to look
amazing
yeah even even the overwatch two stuff
that's not for us but again it's
something it's the kind of the first
you're seeing it you know the
announcement of free to play and all
this stuff um
so honestly looking back at it
damn near everything that's here
is of is of interest and seems of
quality and
so
it's just one of those things where
i i got taken off guard it is one of
those things that if you tell me a week
in advance hey man expect this kind of
stuff
all of a sudden i'm not going in with
that um and
and not that
i was being unfair to them in that
regard right but it is hard to pivot in
the moment when you had stuff in your
mind
and we've never we've never seen that
right in fairness to you we've never
seen xbox say yo 12 months is all you
from here to here yeah yeah
but everything like the last case of
benedict foxx
fantastic game oh my goodness and and
and
again looking back at pentamen when you
look at the pedigree of who's behind
this game and when you look when you
think about what pentamete stands for
pentamete is is kind of the painting the
meaning of the layers and and it's a
form of storytelling from back then
again if this is incorporated in in in
the way i think adjust so it can do this
game's going to kill and when you talk
about it's funny because i think we've
come to the point now when we think
about what the hardcore wants
i think in the long term only the
hardcore really paying attention to this
game no matter how it looks right i
think if if you get a casual look at
this game
maybe on this if it if it plays simply
on the surface maybe they stick around
but if it's a deep rpg kind of like what
we expect only the hardcore are the ones
that are going to stick around right so
and that's what i want i want it to be a
hard part and there you go right so it's
one of those things where it's like
you're damned if you do your damage you
don't because ultimately the game is a
game for the hardcore it's just not what
you kind of want to see or expect to see
at an e3s presentation right and so
again you know looking at it pentium
seems great grounded has always been
great and now it's 1.0 diablo again if
if they had if the sale had gone through
already and they tell me diablo day one
game pass well diablo still could be day
one because
the you know it's not coming out until
2023 and the deal could close before
then and if it is that's a big that's a
big announcement
this is a massive phenomenal rant in my
opinion
the show for me yeah it is so cool oh my
god yeah diablo 4 was definitely the
cops agreed by the show
yeah for sure okay so before the let the
cops pass but um so the thing on
starfield and like i said before i think
i'm going to play starfield i'm
thoroughly going to enjoy star field
but my thing is just this right when you
look at it
i look at
kind of the way they were blindsided a
little bit with fallout 4 and having had
witcher 3 be as good as it was and come
out months before
and so my thinking going into starfield
you know after the 76 stuff and whatnot
is hey my my hope that my thinking my
hope was that they look at their formula
and be like all right i want to change
up the game completely i'm going to come
and we're bgs damn it we
are the standard bearers for the western
rpg let's show them right
and what felt disappointing to me was
it's just an it feels like it's an
evolution of their formula and that that
todd's mantra is
bigger is better right so it's just take
what we've done before polish it to a
fine shine and make it bigger and like i
said during the show for me when i look
at what i want out of a next-gen rpg
i'd rather smaller
and denser and feeling more alive as
opposed to expansive scope i know where
you're going i the only other
interruption i will say is
i think
philosophy wise you're going to be
disappointed because
yes historically bethesda has always had
those larger scope
type of games where actually you need to
come over to team obsidian like out of
worlds
is that tougher
denser more
you know concise story that's the same
stuff but you know what i'm saying in
the narrative writing
right i think that you're like
that's what i mean by games that have
come out since right even in their only
like set you know you look at new vegas
same thing it's like the con
to me
the
if if and i'll forgive them for this if
the if the bespoke
parts of star field the created parts
the the stuff that's not procedurally
generated if that stuff is denser and
feels more alive and feels like they've
they've taken that formula to another
level is there
i forgive them for the expansiveness but
for me it's just again i i i completely
agree that since
that's what it is
oblivion these massive things i know i
guess what they do get it and my my
heart in my heart of hearts what i hoped
was that they looked at what what has
come since and i talked about oh you
know
and i and i talked about uh cyberpunk
and then you know when you get a version
of cyberpunk on pc running and looking
beautifully that game does things
that takes the idea of of a living world
to another level and the density and and
the realism and you know getting away
from the the uncanny valley stuff right
so that's kind of that was my hope and
expectation for this and maybe in parts
it's going to be that right but in parts
that they showed here it just felt like
hey this is our formula this is how
we've improved upon it and it to be fair
everything seems improved upon we we
have really seen real combat so i hope
it's better i don't want to see bats i
want to see i want to be able to shoot
normally and stuff like that
but it just that's that was my
disappointment in it that i exp i
expected more from it but again they
know what they're doing within the
constructs of the formulas that they've
that they've created because they
created a lot of this template yeah um
and i know i'm going to enjoy it it's
just
i just saw everybody saw what it started
to be something stuff about what it
started to be and i get it
it went into their traditional formula
and but with a bigger scope but i know
where you're going i know where to fly
that's a philosophy thing but um okay
but i'm gonna change my i gave it a six
i'd give it a six
i it's
7.5 to me even closer
yeah because i i'm really really just
analyzing the stuff that they talked
about and the fact that it is coming out
within the next 12 months there's a lot
to look forward to it's maybe not what i
expected in the e3s show
but i can't front like this there's a
lot of cool stuff here so you're you're
basically saying that if you had known
it was 12 months only before the show
your initial reaction would have been a
lot higher than a six
right if you had known that before 100
100 because we would have had better
expectations going into the show that
prediction show
it would have been set up different it
would have been like look like you know
this is a 12-month basic like in my in
my mind i didn't expect the vow to be
you know people were speculating that
about could be a a shadow drop this year
i didn't
i didn't expect that but like to
addict's point they've had they've had
the bulk of these studios since 2017
2018 boxing burger said the same thing
show me something yeah it has to be
something i'm with you because part of
e3 is the super bowl the
circumstance the wonder the joy and
that's where i align with like we just
got the play yeah it's like oh you're
just giving me the play yeah like you
just give me what's coming up this year
and i'm like it feels like yeah and it
feels like when there's no sense of that
competition that there's always been
there's no need to go above and beyond
right and i i think i'm so i think
boston burger said it best if you take
out the three of those games that we
kind of felt we knew about
you know the eso's the sea of thieves
and i've got what the third one was the
fallout 76
and you throw just maybe one or two
even if it's like remember when a vow
first got shown and they show the arrows
and the thing and you're like you see
the spell even if it's a cgi to say okay
compulsions working on something okay
you know this one he you know or about
something of one of the studios to get
the wonder okay what are they doing
because i think to addicts frustration
right when you we know about 2018 we
know they got all these two it's like
well what is an exile doing what is you
know if it wasn't for randolph or just
gordon we wouldn't know these codes
but but the
layman is like how you that is on the
phone's like oh how you bought all these
studios what are they doing and i think
they did need to give a little wonder i
don't want to spend too long because i
know we go i didn't expect to stand to
go this long but i wanted to get the
actual extended showcase of that i
wanted to get that part on and as far as
skipper ran like you know now that that
came out what are your thoughts about it
how did you feel about the extended
showcase specifically
uh well i thought the best thing from
the extended showcase was the thing they
showed of uh
uh stalker two and the uh devs and the
crane that was crazy
uh
other than that
stunning showcase ain't for me
like i
just
i i don't know i just kind of
lose all interest when people talk for
long periods of time so
i know valheim was announced for xbox
which is pretty big that was a pretty
big pc game he's coming to pc and xbox
yeah
i'm struggling
paris had a segment with flight sim when
he was in
i honestly don't even really remember
like when i think of the extended
segment i think of how they ended it
with stalker two
and that like emotional video yeah of
what they're going through other than
that i just
i'll be honest like i don't remember
remembering no texas chase oh mascara
i felt like last year's extended was
better
okay okay
let's phrase that with it boxing burger
uh sir extended showcase thoughts
i really enjoyed it i love
these um insights and behind the scenes
uh looks and the interviews i do love it
and i appreciate that they don't pack
that in the main show they have a
dedicated
um extended showcase where people like
me that enjoy stuff like that
can get these infos and i actually
thought a couple of games that
really showed better in the extended
showcase like a pentiment yes
it got my confidence back
i was shaking there you go but um i i
really thought uh that it was a way
better showing in the in the extended
showcase when you got a little
um
background as to what what it's supposed
to do or high on life everyone like was
on my reaction show after the the the
first xbox showcase uh super excited for
hire live and i said
didn't do much for me but
those thefts were really funny guys when
we got a little insight on why these
guns are talking and stuff
i i and the level approach how you can
from each with like how you can attack
the game from different levels depending
on where you are with what what guns you
got the progression the way you get the
progression in so much player choice but
continue
yeah no so i i thought some of these
games really shot better in the extended
showcase
um
so yeah i enjoyed that and like grant
said the ending was super strong oh
yes like um
yeah it is it isn't easy for a big
corporation to do something like that um
to get all political and stuff and
um i really have to upload microsoft for
doing that it was a very strong
statement at the very end stalker 2
looks continues to look amazing that
that intro sequence is fire um
i can't wait it was already one of my
most
anticipated games
um big fan of the ogs
so yeah
i i thought this was was a
pretty pretty good um showing yeah so no
doubt i enjoyed it no doubt lord addict
extended showcase thoughts
it was good um
i i like these extended shows because i
feel like
they can do what they previously
saw
that's not me all right
they come up with something
at least how it's completely different
so it's not me
attic you want to run
i i don't even hear anything all right
you're going down that whatever
um
i these shows are used for things that
you know the main show can't do like
breakdowns and stuff like that so
it's it's got is it's
it's uh
it's place but i i do feel like the
the pacing to the extended show was kind
of uh not there either it's like look i
don't think these shows are designed at
pacing either but it's just like i i got
about 40
look a couple announcements into it i
turned it off so not for you not for you
not fair not fair enough lord sav
extended showcase her thoughts
um
i think this extended showcase does what
it's meant to do which is give you an
extended look of things that they showed
in the in the main sort of presentation
i don't
i don't i'd rather the things that they
announced here i would have rather just
seen quickly at the at the big uh
showcase i think it just would have
added value to that showcase especially
something like i talked about earlier
along with the riot games thing is
valheim coming to
game pass as a console exclusive
bellham was like last january
not this year year before like valheim
was all the talk was all the talk on the
pc side obviously
yeah yeah so obviously they kind of
missed that
you know initial wave right they didn't
have that
but i do think
putting it on game pass expanding that
game out to another audience could kind
of give it a research i have not looked
to see how valheim is doing now but i'm
sure that the hardcore that love that
game are continuing to love you know
play that game so
just like the riot stuff it is another
reason to sort of
bring in the pc center cloud even though
this is a console thing um obviously my
thoughts is that it's coming to pc game
pass as well but this is huge um texas
chainsaw looked interesting
um i'm you know i love horror movies so
to see this and see what they kind of do
with this
sure i want to see it i would have liked
the quick sizzle reel of it at the uh at
the main showcase beyond that like the
like the stalker 2 stuff was cool
because it's us it
when you see devs taking up arms
um and being like hey i gotta handle
this and you look at that person and you
have no idea if you'll you know god
forbid this person does not survive this
um
or you see a dev that lived in a hallway
uh for months on end um continuing to
figure out a work thing in the midst of
all of this is is kind of insane
but um beyond that yeah i just think i
think it has its purpose i'm glad that
they've realized that talking to devs
and stuff for long periods of time
during the main showcase doesn't go over
well
and but i'm not the guy for this either
like when i'm in on a game i don't want
to hear much more about it no matter how
excited i am about it
when i'm in
i'm in and i don't want to see much more
so uh it has its place i think it does
that well
but it isn't really for me not fair
enough i jump in at it too much i just
want to shout out malik paris and lt i
actually thought they did sure a really
good job with the interviews i like
malik with um pete hines specifically i
felt he asked very good questions you
know i thought i got some more
information on red fall again i'm still
excited about that
um you know for me there was some gets
obviously the texas chainsaw massacre
the vowelheim stuff there's stuff that
wasn't announced there was a was it a
ara untold uh the
you talk about gameplay but this game
showed up with no gameplay and it sucks
because i usually like those the genre
and i love the actress the voice act
they have for i forget her name i think
she's iranian she's amazed she's a
destiny she's one of my favorite
characters and i i felt like i know
that's a game that should be a decent
get for them but i thought i learned
more about it on the extended showcase
so to me it could have been them
especially where they're coming from
with the uh civilization and x-com guys
yeah
that appeals to me so i'm just like okay
you should at least whatever whatever it
is what it is but um yeah and i think
that the standout is actually didn't
mind it you normally i usually cringe
with stuff like that i felt i got a lot
more information i think even um
playground was in the building for a
little bit giving us more about hot
wheels yo yo
that hot wheels look fire bro yes yes so
salute to them i thought it was good
paris did his thing he's out there
moving around and smithsonian you know i
was happy to see the people outside so
the show hit different from me and i got
to give sarah bona credit she got really
emotional during the um
the stalker two thing you know what i'm
saying world announcement yeah yeah that
was really it hit home because look i
know people like you i don't care about
you know the pandemic and the games
where the games and it's like bro
there's real life stuff going on you
know what i'm saying and i think to me
even sometimes i get into i mess up i'll
be like yo what's up with these games
where it's at and then it's like yo
dudes are fighting for their life the
studio had to get evacuated you saw like
before and after so it's like when you
look at the real life situation you look
at the pandemic that all studios are
dealing with i know people like you are
just exercising but yo every major first
party triple a from sony got delayed at
some point ratcheting clank horizon for
middle west same thing with nintendo i'm
still waiting for breath of the wild too
it is real we can't act like it doesn't
exist you know what i'm saying
the only difference between let me let
me finish
the key is the key is that i feel that
with xbox and i know where you're going
at it that from what you want to call it
mismanagement
or no proper planning
i feel that when their delay happened
with those two there was not a
contingency so to speak that they could
fall back and maybe stalk stalker was
part of that you know say if it was a
time exclusive so to speak but it just
it just exposed the whole a little bit
for 2022 from a first party perspective
but that's what i wanted i just want to
say like i think it's gamers we have to
be a little bit conscious and cognizant
of what's really going on with that we
got it i don't know
no i was going to say the only
difference between microsoft and sony is
it seemed like sony had a couple more
games further in development than
microsoft did at that time so absolutely
and not
i've been told firsthand that like
the more people you have to go around
the harder it is to manage people in a
situation like that too so yeah you know
when you have a lot more studios that
you have to constantly go back and forth
between it's going to be harder to keep
everyone
on the same page than you know uh the
smaller amount of people that sony has
to has to manage right now because i
mean
at this point microsoft's almost got
double the studios that sony has
yeah i just think i just think if we
if we're not hearing
rumblings of
constant reboots and games possibly
being canceled and stuff like that which
is what we were hearing a lot of you
know sort of during the xbox one
generation in fact we're not hearing
about that sort of stuff behind the
scenes and it is just delays
i just think that the mismanagement sort
of conversation is a little bit
overblown i i like to addict's point at
the boxing burgers point yes there are a
lot of studios and maybe they need to
figure out a way to sort of keep the
hand on the pulse of each studio a
little more frequently or just
get the temperature of these two studios
more frequently but um i think if there
was true mismanagement
we'd be hearing the same sorts of
stories of like you know uh
cancellations you know this thing that
they talked about is quietly cancelled
and stuff like that we haven't heard
that and that may just be them learning
you know you know to sort of handle pr
better and not let that stuff out right
but i don't think that's necessarily the
case like even
you know we've heard things about about
being rebooted once or twice in in
development i haven't heard anybody come
out and be like oh about is in trouble
right um it's just one of those things
that happens during the course of
development and i think that's one of
those things that i've become more
sensitive to when i talk about this
stuff is just the fact that
if you think about game development from
the very beginning
it it doesn't seem like there's any any
formula that you can go by from game to
game to say hey this is going to bring
me success right
every every game is a trash fire until
it's not and it doesn't even feel like
the processes are necessarily the same
so it's like it's like
literally rebuilding the wheel
every time you start a brand new game
because the challenges are going to be
different to different the you know the
atmosphere is going to be different
it's just everything is different so
i've just i've just gotten accustomed to
the fact that everything is going to be
delayed sometimes we'll hear about it
sometimes we won't and
which will give us the impression that
the game never had any issues during
development which is never the case
right and that's just kind of the
mentality i carry into when when i talk
about this stuff now it's like man
everything is is a trash fire until we
get the final product and that's it and
that's kind of the way i think about it
well okay go right well so say like the
whole mismanagement thing is only going
to go away once xbox starts releasing
all these titles and they're good
they're good proofs in the pudding
however
the one thing nobody really mentioned
about this whole 12-month thing is
are we sure these games are going to
release in this 12 months yeah what if
they missed the window yeah i think some
of them are definitely pushing past that
especially considering that all the
exciting games we're looking forward to
are more at the back end of these 12
months they're gonna they're gonna hear
it if that's the game you know like
who's to say starfield doesn't need i
think there's a good chance it's like
hey starfield's coming out no you know
11 11 20 23 right like you're setting
expectations now all these games are
2023 and i know they have you know the
asterisk and the the the fine print
that's like you know release dates may
change or whatever
but i mean you came out there saying it
with your chest
this is what you're playing on xbox in
the next year
and you know
maybe they all hit maybe a couple slip
like we we just don't know yeah that's
why who loves them that's a really good
point that's a good point because we
didn't get a lot of dates even with
right that's why it removes them not to
put dates i think that's the lesson
learned
to be honest with you not putting dates
or putting dates it doesn't really
matter at this point you said in a
12-month ratio if those games get pushed
out of that 12 months which i think
there's a good chance starfield does uh
if if it does get pushed out of that 12
months it doesn't even matter you didn't
put that release date on there because
people will be like why are we having an
another e3 and starfish still ain't out
so it's just like they're gonna have to
hit that
and if the game comes out and buggy they
don't get that business for the same
stuff like you know that that's part of
the issue like what what when you're in
this this type of uh business because uh
these
twitter is not a safe haven for a lot of
these places so look
i i i hear what you say right and you
know as far as the the 12-month thing i
think that i'm still going to stand i
think that's the lesson learned you know
you give them as much time as they
possibly need and you don't thought you
don't put your chest out i mean with a
date with legs
todd basically said last week during
that uh the press event that you know
they're putting the finishing touches on
starfield yeah todd also said i mean
they're doing that last time i know i
know i'm just saying what what okay so
what do we think which game is coming
out first red faller star field right
fall red flag
red fall okay and we all think i i don't
i don't think starfield comes out till
like august september of next year
oh wow
ooh i think star well here's the thing i
remember i remember going to j i
remember going to [ __ ] to this too and i
mean like start and cogs like it's it's
[Laughter]
i don't know i think i think starfield
is the one
well i'm not going to say a lot but i
think it comes out in the fiscal year
their fiscal year ends at the end of
june
i think they desperately
want these games all to hit
they desperately wanted that game to hit
2022 too and it didn't happen so but the
thing is though like
i don't know if that necessarily matters
too much because it's those that's still
within the same fiscal year right to
them at least right yeah um but
i think the question has to be asked
let's go let's go
what's up with taylor infinite bro
please show up at that or
you know you had you had to see a theme
yeah you had fallout 76 you had elvis
grows online
their biggest game halo infinite
no shows now if you want to talk about
potential mismanagement see this is this
is the thing and i see the miss
management talk about xbox as a whole
to me
there is one offender
there is one
one of these kids that you know part of
the children
have been not you know
making their homework assignments on
time they've consistently shown and i i
love you know i love halo infinite as
the game the core of its game is fun
the gameplay is great
you know what i mean no one's saying the
game is bad it's just seen anyone i've
never seen a live service game
not have service available
live like like i just like like that
that's the problem like
i don't know what happened
that did you go just everything was just
to get across the finish line and now
it's like let's play catch up because
that's the problem and to me it's
indicative if it's not there listen i'm
happy takes my time today because
clearly that right right so
to me if it's not there
that i have to internalize it i'm gonna
have to guess that you still need more
time for project to talk and the battle
royale you still need more time for the
co-op you still mean no time which i'm
not gonna sugarcoat it is unacceptable
in my opinion i've always been on delay
halo until it is ready i never was on
that bring it out you know just because
it's the 20th anniversary and we need it
forza horizon was doing fine by itself
in that holiday window i'm going to die
on that sword a lot of halo fans mad at
me no cog it needs to come out are you
happy now
are you happy with the level of content
you're receiving right now i do this
live service stuff i play the live
service games i know how it goes you got
to have content and on top of it it's
free to play so if you're free to play
and you still i mean you're doing well
on xbox
but the steam numbers you you can't say
that they did not envision a way bigger
engagement and player base so yeah they
they did that to themselves you know and
to me it's unfortunate because of what's
happening at 343 i'm not going to say
you know obviously undead labs
initiative those to me i don't say
problems those are the people what three
i think people look after the microscope
the most when the mismanagement talk and
i can't dispute those three
i can't sit there and say yo no it's
definitely not because i have to go
about what we see right but in fairness
i want also people to say this why i
don't get on their mismanagement
training because we're not talking about
obsidian we don't talk about playground
holding it down we don't talk about
coalition holding it down you know what
i'm saying there's a lot of xbox game
studio that's doing just fine and doing
what they're supposed to be doing you
know what i said so that's all i'm
saying you know it's like you know what
what's going on with them but to your
question yeah i think it is
disappointing with 343 in the halo
infinite situation i i'm surprised that
they weren't there i think i i think
the free-to-play thing and i said this
from the beginning before this game came
out i'm like they're turning halo into
something that it's not it has or hasn't
been before
and
looking at what bungie's gone through
looking at things that have happened
with anthem the division we've seen the
blueprint of what works and what doesn't
work and it feels like
this is the aspiration they had for but
for halo multiplayer and they weren't
prepared
for the amount of work and the amount of
manpower required absolutely up that
cadence then the delay and the other
thing and here's the thing
and i've i've done this live service
here's the thing in fairness to them
because shout out to my man who's in
there i am like that's capcom you played
dessert absolutely that i've played
destiny one and in fairness to halo
infinite this is what i will say about
how the live service thing go they
dropped to tonka they which is the
battle royal they dropped the co-op they
dropped the forge and it looks good
plays good you got a good trailer all
let's forget live service people come
back that's the thing it's ebbs and
flows
you know what i'm saying halo i mean
destiny had the problem in the beginning
launched it did have content though
that's the difference destiny had
content they had a raid they had
divorced the glass they had expansions
so it's not a one or a destiny had
conditions the narrative was where that
was but you know at the end of the day
these guys got to drop content if it's
good content people will come back my
thing is it didn't need to be this way
you didn't need to put you you this is
self-inflicted in a way
good i'm actually in the mindset that uh
they they might have killed the uh halo
franchise trying to turn it into a free
to play we'll see it's up to them
damn
you know it's just i don't know that
team is not built for that and that's
what's saying i don't think 343
it has the expertise and
the the output that they that that is
needed to deliver a free to play halo
like if you look at epic
epic is all hands on deck on fortnight
and they shut everything else down one
game one game yeah
um
yeah listen anybody who says that i
cannot fight dispute
hey we got we we have a track record we
have a track record right that's what
i'm saying we gotta be honest we gotta
we gotta see
we're gonna have to see what happens
when they put that battle royale yeah
that that might breathe a lot out of
life i will say this it's kind of like
this is it like when you get that hot
trailer
you see 60 spartans dropping down you
know what i'm saying battle you're going
to see red like yo battle royale with
the crew he go grab up go for he go grab
up his people and if it's fire gamers
won't forget you if it shows well gamers
going gonna be okay halo's back here we
go i just want the overall health of
halo to stay strong because to me this
was supposed like that if it was delayed
last part i know we go long if let's say
it came out
at the top
first quarter 2022
that would have helped a little bit with
this year and you had kind of i don't
think it would've helped much i'm just
saying if you had content steady content
and it was ready and rocking it would
have helped a little
with this gap of of 2022 first party
that's all i'm saying yeah
i mean what are they realistically
released in that little gap between
release dates like they haven't really
done much yeah i'll say what if they had
the time and that would have afforded
them the time that to drop a co-op of
forge and a battle royale mode and it's
like yo look at all this content halo
got it but at least but those but i
haven't got i mean we're probably still
three to six months away from all of
that stuff so i i still think we'd still
be the exact same situation
which would be like january 2024
we'll see i'll pull it for them i want
to launch it right in between stuff
there you go add it it could have been a
starfield spot
i know a little bit i know a little bit
information when it comes to the 343
stuff that there was a lot of variables
that led you to wait dude there was just
one or two there was a lot as much as
i'm talking i still think the game is a
great game i wouldn't go this hard for
anyway let's move on solving's getting
some chats and then we got more
okay cool we got a bunch so let me
scroll back a little bit just remember
the last one that i got is brett bingham
that's the last one that i have all
right
salute everybody in the chat doing what
they do make sure you guys hit the like
button for the lords come on thank you
yeah hit that like man you know since
the lord's day it's free it's easy
one of the best podcasts out there one
of the best xbox ones
[Laughter]
i don't know what the hell you're
talking about right now
you ever seen them
all right i'm ready to rock all right
let's do it
we got ryan two dollar super chat hey yo
king got that crocs link oh
on the crocs chain oh king not showing
up today at all he said he's gonna try
to pop in
we'll see
uh we got a taco five dollars
it's not really a new concept nintendo's
always announced things that are within
a year in their directs yes but a lot
oftentimes for nintendo a lot of stuff
is supe super secretive like they don't
let they don't let stuff out of the tree
house like so
we got to be realistic with nintendo too
they make great gains but like i would
say
the difference between their games is
something like star food and golf fall
uh not godfall god of war
it it's it's huge difference like you
know i i look at something like the
pokemon games and like kirby those games
take a long time to develop but i don't
think they have to jump through nearly
as something like a star field
yeah
that's true okay one second
then we got uh
murky murky with the 35 actually these
are called rants
south african rands shout out to red
murky berkey 35
here all the way from south africa and
i'm a bit late on this on this one but
what about the classic capcom arcade
piece cadillac's and dinosaurs did you
guys play that
good i know what it is i don't think i
ever played it though i played it it's a
real pretty game it's back you know i
think this system system
system two sort of uh capcom stuff um
beautiful but i it wasn't an ip that i
knew
um
we got necromancer's ale remember the
difference between a nintendo game and
an xbox game is probably 200 million
dollars
wow slander
we got this showcase was for everyone an
all-around showcase for the next 12
months their next showcase later on will
be showcasing their future games and
gameplay trailers for 2023.
that that is a hope and we have bay area
five dollars we chat
happy father's day to all the real ones
out there great show hit that like
button thank you certainly hit that like
button save the children every time you
hit the like save you save catch out
and we got rob the don 202 two dollar
super chat let's get those likes up
thank you yeah
man come on father's day for the fathers
not for the babies today but for fathers
man come on
kate johnson member for five months
thank you sir back with some awesome
guests loving iop rand al tomato 2023 is
the year of the camps being 2023 is the
year of the cams being on the show oh oh
randolph what how many subs you need to
get your kids 200 000. oh come on i
thought it was one of these you keep
moving
like it's like the haters of xbox like
he's like i'm gonna i'm the man with the
million i need a million subs that's it
what else we got we have
rob the don again two dollars uh ten
dollars with a chat
let's hold on if the games aren't ready
and they show a second cgi or choppy
trailer this will ruin the game more
than not showing it so the best thing is
to let people people's imagination run
okay yeah there ain't nothing to imagine
there was no announcement
and we have hard to find member for 14
months thank you sir shout out to my
guys as always much love make sure y'all
hit that like button guys hit that like
button
then we have luna smoke zim with the 5
super chat thank you sir
then we got flame member for 21 months
in the building
my favorite reveal of the xbox showcase
was the return of waiting for e3 2020
well that's messy don't act like there
wasn't no games for you playing that's
best
really got me hyped have a great show a
little bit flavors as always
as his name and indicates is dropping
fire exactly
then we got slow mo back slap 1 super
chat
xbox needs to retool inside xbox it's a
quarterly show that provides reveals of
first party games and updates on the
development of anticipated games yep
that would definitely work yeah
and we got luna smoked zim once again
ten dollars we chat
aaa games are just not ready for anyone
what the sony nintendo ubisoft capcom
take two or ea have for the triple a
2022 gt7 god of war and horizon are all
last gen games deep into development
before the pandemic that's true okay
okay
we got necromancer zeal once again 5
super chat i've seen stories on new halo
infinite campaign story content isn't
coming out until 2025 is that what
you're hearing right jesus
i don't know can you confirm i have no
idea you know maybe maybe you know maybe
what they should do is just can the
10-year plan and just release a new halo
game in five years
interesting yeah wow yeah okay
what else we got all right uh thx 1138
five dollar super chat obsidian is able
to develop game ideas under microsoft
that no way any other any other
publishers will never greenlight we get
to see more games from the studio that's
for sure 100
and they get to exist they get to exist
because of that bag
and we got pragmatic eagle 10 super chat
people like to poop on games that hit 20
plus million players then don't buy the
one game they cap so hard for as
indicated by the sales engagement
numbers etc it's hella weird to me just
play games that goes to show you that
twitter isn't a real place and a lot of
people just like to talk for the sake of
talking twitter's echo chamber do not
look yeah i agree i agree what he said
because a lot of people like even though
we may say that's not for me some of
those franchises that they did pick up
are tremendous player bases and huge
engagement especially specific reasons
but yeah which is the reason why sea of
thieves is at the show every year
because yeah exactly
30 million people so it's constantly
it's constantly meeting
new people so of course it's going to be
there it's just like that fall out the
elder scrolls online though it's like i
feel you i see yeah i i couldn't these
rare puts i mean the trailers rare make
are really really yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know that's a good point
yeah rob the don two two or two ten
dollars a which i'm sorry we knew they
was in trouble when they moved starfield
and red fall people was hoping that they
would move something up or show the
future they didn't they didn't now
people don't have ammo for the council
oh man the playstation guys are going to
clown me yep uh for the next year so
there is
there is an element to that exactly just
just be just be prepared for that
clowning if uh god of war comes out this
year and it comes out on 11 11 20 22.
just just be ready
more fuel for the game for the fire
god of war ain't coming
with the exclusive
there we go
even though even though corey ballarat
came back to twitter you come back to
twitter oh we come back to twitter
[Laughter]
i'm so sick of like like we almost in
july like july trying to save you for
the playstation nation
um playstation nation can go somewhere
with oh he really didn't show me his
corey ain't showing me god awards bill
we gotta get that emoji yo we getting
the show
at the end of the day they haven't
showed me anything to make me think this
game's coming out this year and like i
wanted to come out this year this year
looking dry like i need some god of war
in my life show us the bill show us the
build attic
pragmatic eagle member for 32 months
thank you sir appreciate that wow thank
you
on a positive note i'm glad all the
discourse is positive and intellectual
salute to iop of course you know what
it's like it's not going down here we
got to keep it intellectual
and we got robbed the don 202 five
dollar super chat plus sorry to be
morbid but why worry about four to five
years in the future when i might not be
here give stuff but i can play now that
is
and we got splendiferous two dollar
super chat i said it saab had to take
that knee boy
was waiting i i don't know when you said
this but okay that's fine okay
i want to see the 150 plus hour gameplay
of when you play
persona 5 because you're not going to
play it
then we have dorian gray 5 super chat
one downside to the bethesda acquisition
is these people who never touched the
bts game coming in demanding stuff
never did and we fans never wanted see
this is this is the thing that i have
with fans of stuff right and then i'm
just not that type of game player people
just want what they want and i respect
that i appreciate that but oftentimes
wanting what you want is not wanting the
thing that you love to evolve and change
oh don't start you're going to piss
attic off it's going to be honest but
you just you just want it you want it
crisper prettier running better that's
it like
it's going to be an argument between
your addict
and i'm not ready for this i'm not
wrong oh god i think would agree with me
i mean if anything i would say that kind
like that mentality is actually what
killed final fantasy they wanted to look
better they wanted to change the
mechanics of or the addict and solve or
the variation of sequence no i'm
agreeing with that okay good
every game got hit by covered but xbox
started from basically nothing in 2018
while nintendo and sony were already in
a good state at that point
interesting
gotta get draft picks got it we gotta
forget it you know get the farm up yeah
and we got beats games life hashtag zim
804 shout out to you sir
five dollar super chat it's it's
mismanagement
has there ever been a console in the
history to launch with no first party
games phil matt booty been dropping the
ball for a while
all i will say i i hear what he's saying
on 2020 and it's a bad look and i feel
that i mean i don't even think it's 2022
like besides um talk about the console
launch
like 20 21. we're going to act like 2021
they happen and they just better publish
in a year besides flight simulator which
is not even a series x exclusive at all
for the horizon five
xbox one xbox one oh you're talking
about but they already told you that
they weren't doing that ahead of time
yeah they told you that it was gonna be
cross-play so that wasn't i don't hold
their feet to that fire like that
doesn't
i just to me i mean 2020 they had they
launched the console in the middle of a
pandemic um
and the thing about it is when you think
about mismanagement again they can't
what okay what if what if they did have
the hand on the pulse and were more had
of an iron grip on these studios during
the process right
does that does that mean that the game
would have come out before it doesn't
necessarily mean that either it means
that they would
exactly it just so it's one of those
things it's like
as a manager you still are sort of
beholden to the work that's being done
and if the games weren't ready they just
weren't ready and no amount of twisting
people's arms was going to get the games
ready in a state that would have been
satisfactory for gamers anyway
so it is one of those things that's like
man
to me solve you got to take they got to
take the l on 2022. it's not about
excuses he just got to take the l they
didn't have whatever happened whatever
happened when the game went ready
and i get it nobody wants to hear it
whatever happened happened what do you
mean starfield and red fall word ready
we know what happened
but you know what happened
this idea that their structure internal
structure is just broken and i don't
know i mean i i said what you're seeing
is
the consequence of microsoft slate
investment in xbox oh yep right and they
have a lot of internal studios that go
buy some but they buy these studios that
already have games that they're working
on like in exile was we got to do
wasteland 3 which they had put on 2019
so they can't start working on anything
new you know
ninja theory is working on bleeding edge
obsidian's already doing some of these
things like a lot of their studios that
they acquired already had previously
scheduled arrangements i mean even
bethesda themselves had death loop and
ghostwire tokyo you know caught up with
playstation and then
what happens nobody could predict uh the
global pandemic happened so now all your
games essentially get pushed almost a
year
right so like avowed and all these
titles
that were probably internally scheduled
for 2022
all suddenly are now 2023 and later
and you're left with the situation where
you didn't really have a lot of stuff
you could have held things from 2020
because 2020 had
ori and tummy tell me why and
a few other games that they really
dropped in the summer just like
before the console launch they could
have held
they decided not to so you launched with
gears tactics
right halo gets delayed psychonauts gets
delayed so 2021 looks better otherwise
it would have just been forza
uh you know bethesda was kind of the
band-aid that we okay we'll get some 20
22 games
and then those get delayed and you're
and you're just you don't have anything
because the games that were supposed to
come are all delayed
so it's just yeah i mean it's basically
and to me it's just if xbox had waited
they waited so long to do all this stuff
and it finally caught up with them it
finally bit them in the ass
so now as boxenburger likes to say like
boglenberger's like there's no first
party games this year even though there
are two
uh you know as does falls which is a
global publishing game they consider
party impentiment right [ __ ] bring it
back
nothing on a triple a scale it just it
just all caught up with just everything
just caught up with them
and probably death loop right
yeah and definitely
at the end of the day
people who say that there's
mismanagement at microsoft like
microsoft's just gonna have to take that
criticism until they prove that they're
wrong because there's been enough to
actually feel like there is
mismanagement and there's nothing on the
other side saying there's not i just
told you stuff what i'm saying that's
saying it's not it's it's multiple
examples of of it not being we they just
came off of 2021 when they published a
year whether people don't like specific
hardcore gamers don't specifically like
flight sim or age of empires or forza
horizon or halo infinite that's one
number we can't say they didn't exist
now this year i ain't making no excuses
for it i wish i mean i'm with you to be
fair though the past six months there's
probably three or four articles that's
that's giving one for everyone that
you're giving what's your name what's
what's the article that they said
initiative thing what was the article
that said that they were not the
publisher of the year in 2021
they had more games than sony that year
i'm not arguing about that i was saying
that
there is plenty of articles of of stuff
that is showing that there might be
something there's three
there's the initiative
the undead lab situation in 343. and i
can give you playground games obsidian
turn 10 you know what i'm saying and
they still got more games coming from i
mean no one i don't think no one's ever
said all of microsoft didn't actually
but that's that's that's the thing that
i i'm just i'm not saying you're saying
that i'm just saying the perception we
have to be honest with the rest of the
studios as a whole and that's what i
think is not being fair now if you want
to say
hey what are the new studios doing i'm
with you right because i think that's
what the issue is i think the issue is
the new guys
hey what's going on and because they did
this 12-month format right and now we
don't see what the new guys are doing
for the most part still then it's going
to be it's on them whether or not they
want to show that or not and i get that
even if you look at from like standpoint
now jason schreier just said on reddit
that vowed has has been restructured so
don't expect to see it anytime soon i
like that there's stuff there
okay but that that means i don't that
means obsidian didn't give us out of
worlds they didn't show us auto worlds
too they didn't show us pentamete they
didn't [ __ ]
around management has to be like the
whole studio
so what so so basically this management
is one game gets delayed then this whole
studio's miss management then that's
what you're saying if one game gets
delayed you can manage one project under
a studio okay so that means the whole
studio is mismanaged
okay so they wouldn't understand why the
evol thing is coming up when we're
ignoring the other things
all i was saying that i could understand
why people would no i get it i get it
and it's up to them like ran said
to make quality games and show well
that's one there and then then the
perception goes away but until then then
people are going to say
with the stuff that you're bringing up
yeah i mean we talk about this stuff and
speculate about it but at the end of the
day it's like ryan said proof's in the
pudding and people only care about the
end product and they don't really care
how they it it gets there so you know
and that's i mean i guess it's fair as a
consumer it's fair you only care about
the end product but we're kind of not
necessarily regular consumers
um
hold on a second what else we got
give me a moment i started copy pasting
a few more
[Music]
okay let me run back
there we go what was the last one you
read because i think i get
shh
for the podcast
hold on a second i'm not on twitter
okay i got it yeah i got it
uh rob the don two dollar super chat uh
five dollars excuse me um the only thing
that might miss is starfield stop it
turn 10 arcane and mo yang are good
i mean well turn 10's the only one with
the window spring 2023 yeah though
who knows what the other ones yeah
exactly i mean but then everybody
thought turned 10 and forza motorsport
was supposed to be this year exactly so
we got gabriel by choice member for 32
months thank you sir i appreciate that
i am not on twitter and i seem to enjoy
my gaming more because of it amen
there's just so much negativity and
irrational stuff happening there i love
all the games i play on xbox great show
thank you sir donald taco 5 super chat
halo has been doing their own shows and
updates though as long as fords are
still september it'll be fine from then
on that's the hope
david castellanos five dollar super chat
love the podcast keep doing big things
thank you sir
and we got mr irishman two pounds super
chat i think halo's building to a soft
relaunch
damn
brett bingham 10 super chat if halo wars
3 gets green lit
which studio do you think will take it
on relic creative assembly world edge or
blizzard who would you choose to develop
it
in
addict cog
who would i choose to develop it
coalition maybe maybe i don't know
yeah i would say coalition
not the gears tactics yeah that sounds
awesome
jd gamer 10 dollars will be chat let's
start this off right ff7 isn't coming to
xbox until it can land in game pass and
it's going to cost microsoft a grip to
do it so i predict if it ever happens it
won't be until 2025 what say you all
i think if it happens it doesn't happen
until all three parts of that game are
out on playstation so yeah 2020 2030
sounds about right yeah i don't know
it's doctor temp super chat
i like this year's show because it had
actual gameplay my disappointment kicked
in however when i realized that we would
probably have to wait a whole year to
get updates on the vowed etc that's true
then we got hollywood rules 10 super
chat happy father's day uh happy
father's day so smash the like button
another great iop sunday last week boom
this week ran that's great ran the great
excuse we ran the great thought they
should have said the showcase was going
to be locked into 12 months uh to a
12-month span prior yes i think that
would have helped a little bit
then we got gaming forte remember
happy father's day lords show was okay
but just a huge reminder of everything
not coming in 2023 and as always wait no
king i'll wait till next week
shout out to the kids i don't know what
happened he's chilling under a palm tree
yeah the crocs did him
with his cracks they ate his feet
we got spartan goat 17 2 pound super
halo in absolute shambles
gotta act infinite bro
wow damn they want it axed okay okay
jd gamer five dollar super chat side
note what japanese publisher is xbox
going to purchase to combat its lack of
japanese game stigma as soon as
activision blizzard king closes sega
koei tecmo
we'll see i think i don't know about
necessarily acquisitions but
we got spartan go 17 again two pound
super chat xbox got us in the desert
like it's the bible day shake
there we go necromancer sale five
dollars in chat which is the best
advanced gg hydration flavor this is the
cod oh okay so we want the the best i
would go with the sour for the um for
the focus even though i got the side
with me right now the focus is actually
game of thrones but i would say the
energy i ain't gonna front that dream
team punch man is it's fire go hit that
the link's at the top of the description
get that twenty percent off following
days right now go get that
power thank you let's go
and we got donald taco dollars
can we stop moving goal posts no series
x exclusives flight sim don't count no
first party games in 2022 pentamen and
grounded don't count no first party
launch games gears tactics don't count
i get it they don't count
but everybody defines things differently
uh not a couple more we got mexican
zoidberg member for 18 months y'all are
tripping so i bet has these on next
mainline persona game coming day and
date to game pass give this man this
knees back i didn't bet that it was
coming when did i bet no i bet it's not
coming damn day
i still think that personal six day one
ain't happening but we'll see
maybe phil dropped off an extra little
bag you know just for that you know
let me see what else let me see what
else i got jumped a little bit let me
roll back a little bit
oh hold on shout out before you go gotta
shout out the legend tom at least it
became a member wow salute salute
appreciate it man thank you for being
here i do want to say this because i
just see this in the chat and um you
know i think there's a confusion like we
all are gonna agree to disagree
sometimes and it's okay there's a
difference between agreeing to disagree
and someone saying that this is
disrespectful just because you disagree
be an addict will always have a
disagreement all the time same thing
with being solved we went at it with the
whole sega thing same thing with me and
ran you know what i'm saying about the
state of xbox and i'm like yo it's all
lit and he's like i don't know cog i'm
saying you know that's just natural
discourse we have to be we have to be in
a position where we can say things and
be on the other side of it as long as it
doesn't personalize it it's all good so
i just wanted to clarify that that's
that's what discourse is does it mean
that's what strikes have a good
conversation that's restriction for good
doesn't mean we if you feel this i feel
that you're disrespectful no that's not
how it works it's just how he feels that
there's times you're adding me and
you've had this conversation where i
mean you've said yo i feel this you'll
be like yo i feel this and haven't i
come to you i'm like yo addict you was
right bro i got that one wrong and
likewise yeah yeah that's all it is but
i see this thing that if we if i know
it's only if it's being you if being you
disagree they think it's gonna blow up
yeah like they think it's real like
we're not gonna talk to each other nah
bro we we do this like five times a day
this is what me and addict do that's why
i love them like and it's funny because
it kind of only you guys to still kind
of keep that energy
we gotta if you anybody who's new to the
show yeah this is the energy we have
with this one all the time this is the
light version broke up
[Laughter]
the best xbox show ever exactly
and people interesting to hear his
thoughts about it hey what was your what
was your feeling or that cause i i know
you were the opposite side that's your
brother
i mean you know i knew it was because
there's a blizzard showcase and he's a
blizzard fanboy exactly right so it was
oh and he got his starfield and his
diablo and his overwatch like of course
he was gonna love it so
you know it's always a different
perspectives are a good thing you know
sometimes when everybody agrees it can
be
a tad bit boring
you know absolutely i love it i love it
because i love when addict challenged me
i love when everybody challenges and
vice versa that's what makes us learn
and better people you gotta have this
course let's continue
spartan goes 17 two pounds super chat
people disappointed cause fake insiders
keep
yo you coming for real i'm just
i mean i'm not an insider tom henderson
we're going to talk about this next
topic i mean
we got robbed on five dollars in chat
there can still be third party aaa deals
this year and those of us who waited
death loop will still drop yeah more
than likely and there could be other
stuff we talked about um
what we call evil west possibility we
talked about the possibility of arkham
knights uh
so we'll see some nights got them nice
not arkham knights
i don't want an arc in that game
let me see what else we have here
[Music]
tom okay tom henderson this is thank you
sir with the crust of the chat for tom
henderson
um then we see
then we have
lord metroid two dollars super chat king
playing skyward sword in some dark cave
at the moment
with the crowd good
exactly there we have lucasfox 5 super
chat people forget that ninja 30 made
hellblade at a triple a quality bar with
a team of 15 people sleep on hellblade
two at your own risk i mean nobody's
gonna sleep with a whole bunch too it's
like it's like this this comment came
out of the blue like stop beefing with
hellblade too it's gonna be
oh let me see
that's it we're caught up all right
finally attic this is your topic this is
the hot one what's going on with final
fantasy man and something happened was
there a show
yeah they had a uh pretty much they had
their own version where they're going
over information on final fantasy
and uh they ended it with the next
installment to the final fantasy 7
remake franchise which is a final
fantasy rebirth it's kind of interesting
this wasn't at a a sony show
um
i felt like this would have been a good
sony show it's not it's it's it's like
it's like sony's not gonna have a show
this year or something like yeah so you
know um first off crisis score was
announced and it is coming to the xbox
platform uh but
rebirth was announced and uh not only is
remake not coming that's not coming
either
uh so yeah so it does look like you know
microsoft is
not getting
the uh pretty much any final fantasy
game besides a psp game mm-hmm
so
yeah so i wanted i wanted you guys's
opinion on this uh because i had my own
resolved opinion but i wanted to see
what you guys did you dropped two videos
about this you know what i'm saying in
reference to xbox in japan this is a hot
one
i want to start reading outdoor 19
because
the night t come to the front of the
congregation you got the xbox community
state that multiple times did he say he
was a lock addict did he say it was a
lock i don't think he said it was a loss
but you said it on multiple different
occasions
yes you didn't say it on xbox two yes he
did i did three that's three
that's more than one well that's yeah
yeah that's when i got sloth
and idle sloth put the tweet out the
communities it ran outdoors said not
only is it coming
he said it's day-to-day
yeah everybody that's like your friend
said it it's going down so let's go ran
down at the news oh like where where are
we
just saying you missed right the just
say you misread the paper you meant to
say persona just say you mean
i mean rand i can't see you but you seem
a little shorter than you were
[Laughter]
how many times yes i have to say this
but even when i made that prediction i
literally said
this isn't a quote-unquote prediction of
mine oh i am just doing this for fun oh
well for fun for fun i didn't get that
memory i didn't know i don't know how
many times i had to put it out there i
said i don't know anything about this
show i don't know anything i it was
supposed to be a bold prediction maddie
was like give me a bold prediction
i was like all right
final fantasy is finally coming is that
bold enough for you right so that went
within an xbox two because people would
listen to finding duke and i'm like
listen not only is final fantasy coming
it's coming in game pass and it's going
to self launch which it kind of did on
steam uh
but i was just like don't read anything
into this because i just literally made
it up on the spot but of course people
are like oh my god
or whatever and it's like this one
that's not that's not true
you know what's funny is that as soon as
i did that i get a dm for my buddy and
it's like
yeah
you know good nice nice prediction but
you're gonna be wrong because it's not
in development for xbox and uh it's it's
only being announced for steam
so
the following week attic if you listened
i locked that prediction back and i said
listen it ain't happening
uh you know so
you know i you know tell me you listen
tell me you don't listen to xbox 2
without telling me don't listen to xbox
oh
until um i'm invited to that show um
i like that i like that
oh damn okay
it's like what the i i hit you up
it was a super chat like a year and a
half ago you're like addict don't worry
i got you on the net there's been three
sets of people watching
this that's not true we barely ever have
any guests
or random dog for not following through
with addict or okay okay
next up is next up is attic okay you
know from iop you know so
listen this
i'm not surprised obviously
um
square seems to be loving the bag that
sony's giving them giving them lots of
bags
not only for final fantasy 7 remake and
rebirth and the third one but also for
final fantasy 16 and for spoken so i
think sony is just
they want final fantasy
to be associated with the playstation
brand
uh and i think they've have spent a lot
of money so they're basically like you
know what
uh remaking rebirth and whatever the
third is they're never going anywhere
besides pc but you can have that little
those little crumbs you can have
chrysler yeah that looks good
you can have the game that also runs on
a switch
the prequel to the main game you can
have that you're not just not getting
the main game
um
which you know we're finally getting
persona but then we lose final fantasy
it's a tough pill to swallow for a lot
of people
and
the thing that
really i want to know
is
uh i don't
we're where the where are the igns of
the world at where the game spots the
world at you know when
when sony does these deals
nobody says a word
nobody says anything
they're just like oh sony's just
thinking when sony does it right it's
competition when microsoft does it it's
it's wrong
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah addicting
are we applying this a different set of
standards for exclusion no no i'm not
implying i'm writing it in stone you
know when sony doesn't nobody nobody
says anything it's just oh sony's sony's
doing right by their players and look
what they're doing um
you know when when microsoft did the
rise of the tomb raider deal
everybody and their parents were
screaming when's it coming to
playstation when's it coming to
playstation you had outlets asking phil
that day like
tell us now then we're gonna be able to
play this on the ps4
and
to the point where square enix had to
come out and say something then phil had
to like say something he was like well
obviously i don't own the tomb raider ip
and you know
but nobody says anything square about
final fantasy there's there's crickets
there's silence so are you implying rand
that there needs to be a certain level
of questioning to square
on xbox's behalf as to when the
exclusivity i'm just saying you know if
you're gonna if you're gonna flip your
lid over microsoft doing
timed exclusives and demanding to know
when it's come together platforms just
you know i've never seen anybody say
anything to square
about it like
why isn't
final fantasy 7 remake coming
to xbox or the switch for that matter
why
what what's what's up with that i'm
gonna tell you this right now and i i
don't think i i'm gonna be honest i
don't think the back that sony's giving
square enix for ff7 is as big as people
think
i think
straight up i think it's a loyalty thing
you have to understand
ff
the deal between square enix and
playstation at the start of the ps1
generation tremendous
that was a paradigm shifting deal yes
and to this day is paying dividends yes
there is a loyalty there that no amount
of money
when it comes specifically to this
series
i think is really going to break
so
i just it when it comes to that i think
square enix is willing to make those
concessions when it comes to playstation
yeah are they giving them a bag sure
is it as big as we think it is to be
able to keep it away from the other
consoles i don't think so i'm going to
be very honest that you know
you know these japanese executives are
very much about loyalty and stuff like
that and these companies are very much
sort of based in that japanese tradition
you know when you look at what square
enix has been doing lately trimming the
fat and getting rid of their their
western studios that's to that's
grooming themselves to be purchased not
by anybody it's grooming themselves to
make them more palatable to playstation
oh you think that could be going down
a hundred percent my feeling so when it
comes to that's f7
yeah i think the conversations around
ff7
you have to look at it through the lens
of f
seven specifically that game and in turn
the the entire series has become
something that i i think they're willing
to make concessions on playstation's
behalf for so i i think that's just it's
playstation that is that they know that
that is the one franchise they have
above all the others that really stands
out above and beyond it is
many people associated with playstation
and you know even if you have that huge
pedigree it had on nintendo before that
i think
it just doesn't matter shout out to the
cops
every time when i'm talking um
but i think that's it i just think
we have to start getting used to the
fact that
by the time if if there is a chance this
this particular game comes to xbox in
any way shape or form it'll be when all
three parts have already come out
maybe on playstation and pc
maybe maybe there's a slim chance that
maybe when rebirth comes out you can get
part one of remake oh you think they're
gonna get them to always say
yeah
okay you finally get the first one or
but again if that takes if that
exclusivity is however long it may be a
moot point because by that time then a
purchase may go down so you may not ever
see it on xbox so i just think there's a
reality we need to look at and i really
do think that when you look at the
relationship with square enix and
playstation particularly in regards to
final fantasy there's a loyalty there
that i don't think an xbox bag can break
interesting yeah this is rand i'm sorry
if you finish your thought and then i'll
give you guys crumbs here's crisis court
go ahead
it could be the last thing you get it
could be because
all one of it seems all their games are
timed exclusive to the ps5 but yep you
know i mean you can make the argument
that you know assam makes a good point
about maybe making themselves more
attractive to sony for a buyout because
if you actually want to grow final
fantasy and make it into a bigger
franchise this is the exact opposite of
what you want to do right like you would
want to put it everywhere
everywhere is possible i mean
like switch hello in japan switch is
dominating literally everything and it's
not even there so like clearly this is a
financial thing between you know sony
and and square enix
i honestly i i believe they're honestly
i honestly think they're harming
the um
uh the growth of the uh final finances
you're gonna like the poll questions
[Laughter]
i'm done i'm done no this is this is a
spicy one the boxing burger i see you
chomping at the bit what is your
thoughts man that that trailer went down
the final fantasy
7 remake rebirth
and at the end
there was one local
crisis
i i agree with rand yeah i also think
it's it's a it's a money thing someone
in the show
said earlier um
i think sony is trying to attach cloud
um towards the the playstation brand
they really want to make him a face of
one of these mascots for for the brand
um
otherwise i i i
don't know why uh square would do that
uh if it's not really for money and and
the motive behind sony is obvious um so
it is funny how this all went down
because everyone assumed like um yeah
it's gonna be a one-year exclusive and
then they had there was marketing
material that was out that said
initially remember like it was a year
yeah or two yeah sorry
yeah
but
we really don't know how these deals uh
uh are made and i think we will see
something similar with death loop and
ghost via tokyo i mean it's a little bit
different story here because
that's obviously
microsoft that they are dealing now with
but we don't really know how long are
the exclusivity right right i'll assume
it's a year we all assume that good
point but you really don't
know it might be a two year thing or
whatever um
so yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't place my
bets anymore on these
exclusivity deals being only one year
and it's not just with square we we just
don't know how sony plays
these things these days so
yeah i have to decide
oh no i mean i'm sorry if you if it
wasn't for me
no no no i was just again an addict
could relate to this
yes we're destiny fans and i know it's
not a one-to-one relationship but
welcome everyone to the suffering if
you're on the platform that is part of
that is being pushed out right and what
i mean by that is look first of all for
the record
i don't have a problem with this i've
said this multiple times so before the
chat come at me i don't have a problem
with sony dropping a bag and saying yo
that's us to me
that's part of the game if xbox is gonna
come out here with game pass right and
put first party day and date and
third-party games on it specifically
third-party stuff right you know what
i'm saying
let's be honest that devalues
playstation version of it you know what
i'm saying because at the end of the day
if mlb the show's on game pass you know
what i'm saying the consumer that is
aware is gonna be like well i'm gonna go
over there and provided they have they
have the console so the same thing
outriders and so on and so forth so to
me i've always said this is my
prediction at the start of this
generation i said sony's not going to
take this lying down with this game pass
thing they running around snatching up
all these big games and associating it
with this service how you do that is
exclusive content and you say okay i'm
going to say final fantasy 7 remake is
associated with the playstation brand
now we did see marketing material
earlier that said you know at 20 20 you
know it's going to be like a year out so
i understand xbox but i empathize with
the xbox fan in the sense that
there was an expectation that after a
year because there was material that
said it you know like one year it ends
with a xbox one's like cool i'll wait
it'll come
and this is why i said welcome to our
pain as destiny fans because this is
what used to happen to destiny fans with
playstation exclusive content with the
activision deal and so on and so forth
we had hoglaw on and he said
specifically these deals can be extended
especially if they have they see value
so in my opinion that's what happened
somebody's like oh no
this right here is associated with we
want to continue this relationship and
secretly extend it and unfortunately to
the gamer he's not made aware he's
thinking the gears up here it comes and
then it's like oh yo
what's up like now you're going on the
part two and we still ain't got it so
this is what i think you know
there is a chance it's my feeling there
is a chance that it comes but if it
comes in my opinion it'll be after all
three games come out and potentially
like the collector's combined edition
and again
it's up to sony with this contract and i
do agree with solver on some level
there is a loyalty specifically with
this franchise to me final fantasy vii
is part of what gave playstation its
identity and separating from nintendo
with the creation of the playstation
system final fantasy vii is literally
one of the games that put jrpgs in the
map i'm sorry solved final fantasy vii
is the game it is it is a more important
game than six thank you
that's all i'm saying so so for me
they realized that
and it's like yo we are gonna lock this
in you know the other thing i thought
was interesting is that in xbox's defeat
because this is my thing and for xbox
fans are frustrated
i i can't blame ex i know they're trying
to get this game you can't tell me that
if there was a specific bag with the
finances of resources that microsoft
have they wouldn't do it they wouldn't
have done it especially how hard they
went for persona just recently right and
anna dale so it's clearly something that
they can't do anything about because and
also final fantasy 7 in itself the base
form addict right the the old-school
joint is on xbox
the original final fantasy 7 that we
that playstation fans got on the ps4 is
on xbox so i just think this is how they
gonna play i know people don't like it
but that's the game they want you like
yo to go get it that's why i'm like yo
i'm not waiting i'm i'm getting it over
there because i don't know how this go
because i felt that destiny exclusivity
secret energy i felt it and i was like
man we was like yo
we doing that joint over there and we we
did what we did but yeah that's what it
is you know what i'm saying at the end
of the day
you know it it it's going to be a
situation that i think if it does ever
come it'll be at the end and that's the
hope that's the hope i'm not sure so if
you really like the game in my opinion
go get it you know what i'm saying it's
over on playstation if you don't you
don't want to play over there yeah
that's one of you attic that's your
joint that's your topic any other final
things you want to say
yeah i feel like there's a couple
different things you need to account for
this one
i don't think
microsoft this is one of those things
microsoft can't just come in and write a
check to fix i agree i believe
it was rumored a long time ago that
originally
final fantasy 7 was supposed to be
something else this remake and then it
would um they outsourced it remember uh
square enix took in and started doing it
in-house right
because that's the reason it took so
long for final fantasy 7 to come out
because they initially it was supposed
to be something else and i don't think
it was i don't think what we have now
rebirth remake whatever the third one is
originally i don't think that's how it
was supposed to go down i think it was
supposed to probably be just
one game
that literally did one for one the
entire story and then when they
restructured brought it in and the
different kingdom hearts got his hands
on it then he's like let's let's do
different stuff
um
i think you know that probably happened
and i think sony signed contracts back
then
uh so
he they signed contract for that project
so when that project changed they
naturally got all of it you know what
i'm saying
um i i do think that square enix is
setting themselves up to be bought
that's why i don't think these games are
coming out for xbox ever
i think by the time rebirth or whatever
the third one comes out there's a good
chance square enix has neither merged
with someone or they've been bought by
someone
so i i don't think they're
the chances of us getting it's like
really really slim
i also do think that timed exclusive
thing could mean a lot of things
couldn't mean it was time to exclusive
for pc because keep in mind back then
they were very
that's when they were still like we
wanted on our ecosystem we're not doing
anything on pc now they've changed that
that that logic gap so i i do feel like
you know when it comes to this
particular moment
final fantasy 7 is just going to be a
playstation brand like
there ain't nothing you could do about
it
if you're serious about that go buy that
game on playstation right because if you
don't want to and you're waiting for it
to come to xbox newsflash it's not
coming
i don't think final fantasy is coming
period i mean
i will say this and to empathize with
the xbox fan who's going through it
right now i can understand the mixed
messaging frustration because it's like
yo y'all giving me they're giving us all
these other ones why not this one right
and then you just want clarity you
almost say like just outright say it's
an exclusive and it's just the way
unfortunately it's just the way the
industry goes right now i'm i'm not
saying this right i'm not justifying it
i'm just saying i think it also you know
why i think it also hits a little harder
ram
is because we've seen
so many of the playstation exclusives
now go to pc
and pc's also getting it right so i
think that also is part of the
frustration as well well why is it xbox
whatever but yeah i would love for the
jason schreier slash you know a whole or
somebody if they like to see the ideas
of this contract i would love to know i
mean yeah
i really feel like this is one of those
scenarios where i wish the industry is
more transparent when it comes to these
deals
um you know obviously they're not going
to do that for multiple reasons legal
reasons branding reasons they're not
going to tell you something's coming out
for another platform
that doesn't make sense for them
branding wise uh but at the same time
it's like look like i will say microsoft
does need to improve that that japanese
market
but they've done a lot
they have done a lot and i can honestly
say
i come on this show all the time and i
say they need to do more they need to do
more as of right now i'm not saying they
don't need to improve but i see
effort yes
they they got the uh the dynasty game
the fallen dynasty game they they got
persona which a lot of people didn't
think could happen
like literally never happened i'll be
honest
it was looking spooky for me too like
i'm not gonna sit there and act like i
wasn't scared like like yo atlas look
like they doing their own thing and so
i've had valid points and i couldn't i
had nothing to defend it like so i was
just like man they need to get over
there but good to you they got the
kingdom hearts games they got the the
final fantasy games
uh you know sure they're they're missing
these newer ones so that's the ones
people want to play sure we're not
getting 16
uh but i feel like it's was seven seven
in particular
sony came in years ago and swoop these
titles there's nothing xbox can do for
the for the foreseeable future now maybe
you know 16 and and then come out but i
remember directly and i correct me if
i'm wrong rand but a couple years ago
didn't didn't phil spencer come out i
think it was like at an xo or something
and say look i can't give street dates
but we are working with square enix to
bring 14 to the xbox platform yeah there
was interviews about that but they've
actually asked
uh people have asked uh
square about that and their response is
that
they just don't have the developers able
to make
uh to to make an xbox version of final
fantasy 14. so they don't believe that i
don't believe that i mean instead of
saying nothing they've actually come out
and said
uh they just don't have the manpower to
make an xbox version right now
i i personally feel like
sony
has done stuff behind closed doors i
think that might not be money like um
like like saul said i do think a lot of
this has to do with money in terms of
like final fantasy vii but i do think
that square enix might be doing a lot of
stuff out of faith for saudi because
they want to be sold to sony
and they feel like the the more they
scratch sony's back they make themself
more appealing by selling the western
divisions that sony eventually will be
like okay let's let's
let's do this
and i think i think that's the goal i
think the goal is even even if it would
not surprise me if some of these games
don't even have deals they're just
trying to make themselves more appealing
to sony because let's be real here
if you take score enix out of
out of playstation stable they're
hurting they've done a lot for sony
there's definitely so it's like you know
playstation and square enix is probably
the closest i've seen them be in decades
yeah it's going to be interesting to
monitor i will say to saul's point if it
does happen and they like i said they
slimmed themselves down for acquisition
you heard it here first
said count kingdom hearts but you know
what was the chance kingdom hearts is
going to be exclusive oh
i think you know
i mean it just got announced i don't
think they actually come out and said
platforms like they haven't that
yeah that's why you know i i'm giving
microsoft a little bit more of like kind
of like a pat on the back really it's
like you're doing what you can over
there but what's really going to
determine if they're doing good in japan
or not is where's dragon quest going to
be is that going to be an exclusive
playstation persona 6. you got the other
ones there's no excuse not to have yes
the future iterations of final fantasy
that's not 16 and seven and nintendo um
that's that's what my prediction is
my prediction is that's why when we
talked about the showcase i feel that
even though some people feel overall
overall it wasn't like a nine out of ten
for them but i think the impact of the
japanese games i think what they're
trying to do is set the president that
from this point forward
none of the newer stuff is gonna get
busy that's just my guess i have no
insight information we'll see if i'm
right on that but um i think like when
you talk about like persona 6 and you
know the next track because they had the
other dragon quest and yakuza would say
you know i'm saying these are huge moves
in the japanese i think
when you take the bag out are they more
inclined to do it that is true and that
remains if you see my prediction is
i think i think they will but we're
going to see your update to your point
they got to show improve right and when
the new ones come out cause saw go come
right back at me and be like fam
persona 6 where is that why wait wait
how come your logo weight at the bottom
we gonna have this topic again i was
gonna want his knees back then he's
gonna want the d's back and i'm gonna
have to get these back to some and i
don't want to do that so i'm standing on
my protection
move it on all right we gotta get out of
here this is the last joint oh sorry
we're gonna get the super chats get
lined up real quick and then we get this
last joint you are muted i believe sir
oh he's still muted okay so he's he's
doing so we can get the super chats next
or you want me to just go to the next
topic
he's going to go to the next one he's
going next actually i'm here
do you hear anything in the background
no okay okay
gucci
[Music]
okay let's see
rob the don
uh five dollars if you chat
xbox only guys give your hopes up sony
will be buying square quarter one twenty
twenty three crisis core is the last one
if not then it's only a matter of time
okay yeah it could be
we got flame two dollar super chat
playstation can keep final fantasy 7
rebirth i'm good with crisis core
right don't listen to him nobody listens
no way
nobody wants that
crisis
popping off their face well crisis goes
good but it's like one thing i want to
say is like square enix did you there's
no way scoring
didn't expect to get heat over that like
you're going to give us the prequel to
the final fantasy 47 franchise but not
the actual games
yeah
like the the remake got so yeah and
that's why i'm like 100 on you know
like i want i want microsoft to buy
everything at this point because it's
like because it's like sony got no
problem taking games off the table for
us
so it's just like i i kind of want that
same energy like it's fair this isn't
fair this bike's like buying studios and
then
it does studios eventually you know they
come exclusive games i want microsoft to
pop in and just take all so
so these uh sony's lunch money sound
like kick down that exactly look at this
man we're taking over he ain't here
someone got it someone got a feeling
all right then we have um
it's the irishman member for 12 months
lou
great to see xbox fans finally riled up
about final fantasy shame that square
hasn't given them anything to actually
boycott
boycott square enix yeah it's kind of
hard i saw people on twitter saying
they're gonna boycott the game and it's
like i know some of them don't really
play those games on playstation it's
like
are you just gonna do what you were
going to do like not buy it on
playstation
i'm playing that day one on playstation
i'll be right there i got my ps4 right
i'm chilling i'm good
and we got rel remember for seven months
most of media are playstation guys
nobody can tell me anything different
sony can do no wrong in their eyes
[Music]
i don't know all right moving on
and we got mandingo big flick
2 super chat
if pc can break that bag so can
microsoft hashtag ff7 i see pc didn't
break the bag this is playstation like
adding said
just
adding the pc to their ecosystem they
finally no more wall garden we pc is
part of our ecosystem now itself
and we got dorian gray five dollars we
chat shows you how incompetent square is
locking games on playstation where the
brass of that platform says
aren't reaching enough players and
putting games on pc
the games are going to pc as well it
remains to be seen how it's selling and
if missing out on other platforms yeah
and we got rob the don five dollar super
chat i'm with saab loyalty over money
this is advice for xbox fans on twitter
and media and and in real life do not
like sony do do like sony fans deny or
stay silent or if all else fails cap
oh my god that's great
then we got spartan go 17 two pound
super chat bro predictions miss harder
than drake's new album oh
damn
i haven't listened so i don't know
robert slade 5 super chat couldn't the
time frame just be for pc xbox wasn't
explicitly mentioned just that it's
locked to playstation for a year right
i mean i don't know
we need to find out somebody to tell us
yeah and we got lucasfox 10 super chat
with xbox about to own crash and spyro
do you think the ff7 exclusivity is an
effort to protect the association of
popular ps1 era characters with the
playstation brand i mean that is true
when you look at ff it's not just not
not just ff7 obviously that's the first
and most important but eight nine
ten ten two all of that stuff we didn't
start seeing a final fantasy on xbox
until the 360. right was it with 13 yeah
yeah yeah
so yeah i mean definitely it it it's a
playstation thing
and we have donald taco well it wasn't
it was a nintendo thing it wasn't a
nintendo switch for sure people forget
that that is true people think oh final
fantasy and and yeah there you go
they left nintendo because nintendo
wanted to do cartridges yes
shout out to the n64 cartridges yes that
was the deal historic
oh no taco 5 but if kingdom hearts 4 was
exclusive it would have been announced
as such i said the same thing about
street fighter 6 and look what happened
street fighter 6 is everywhere yeah
right then we have edward walton five
dollars super chat are we are we also
not looking at the relationship that
microsoft has a fairly good relationship
with sega atlas's parent company fantasy
star is exclusive
i mean fantasy star is well fantasy star
so far yeah the the fantasy star online
like
what online two whatever that's a new
game essentially and they didn't really
market it as such but it is new yeah
it's exclusive so far nobody else is uh
i don't know how it's doing though to be
honest it kind of came and went out and
see too many people talking about it
then we have jeffrey rivers hold on i
gotta jump dammit
jeffrey rivers in the building five
dollar super chat haven't heard anyone
on the xbox side explain the s i e ff
deal like that before and think that
that and i think that's exactly what it
is sie and ff are associated together
i think
i mean
ff7 leaving nintendo and going to
playstation in a lot of ways that cox
said that brought jrpgs to the
mainstream in a way that had never
happened um so that's it's huge
uh let me get donald taco two dollar
chat drake's new album is ballon
wonderland bad hashtag just say it's one
it's wonder world sir
hate coming in on drake
salute there we got spartan go 17 2
power super chat don't listen to it son
wish i had my 50 minutes back damn damn
i heard he's trying to be on some some
some some kind of like club thing i
don't know like
that's crazy let's see
um let me see what else i got jumped a
little bit hold on
yeah a minute we got a man bingo big
thickets
i want the sony guys to keep that same
energy when microsoft buys up more large
studios they're okay with sony locking
games up yet when microsoft does it it's
treason
oh my god you know how it goes
console exclusives will be dead within
the next 10 years subscription
exclusives will take over xbox will get
ff eventually uh the question is when
yeah we shall see yep let's see we'll
see what's going on so he sells
playstation to microsoft
well you better hope for the
trilogy complete super deluxe edition
with all of them rebirth remake whatever
anyway last time this was king's topic
really quick on playstation now he
wanted to talk about this
playstation now loses more than 200
games in their uh their new playstation
plus service so it looks like um as a
result obvious obviously that all the ps
premium and the players plus extra game
list that had the hundreds of games but
some of those game current some of the
current ps now games will be included in
that list but that means that now
playstation now loses more than 200 of
their games so there's a long extensive
list of this there's been talk online
some frustration with certain aspects of
it i don't know how if anyone has been
following this story i really wanted
kings out a site for this because this
is his topic so if anyone wants to jump
in if boxing break i know if you heard
anything from this it's itself any any
information i will open this up to the
floor i mean
the thing about it is this right they
haven't the the assumption
is that ps now goes away right now that
this new sort of consolidated ps plus is
in effect
the thing is they have not announced
that specifically so ps now you can you
can literally go out and still purchase
ps now piecemeal
apart from this ps plus thing so
yeah for those of you who only want ps
now
and don't want to
go in to jump into these new tiers of ps
plus
yeah you're gonna for whatever reason
these games are leaving that that part
of it and going into the
the new ps plus
um
the thing about it i just don't
understand they gave enough
lead way right why didn't they just say
as of this date ps now no longer exists
it only exists
in these ps plus tiers right okay the
problem with it is that
the the ps now streaming tiers and the
downloadable stuff
does not translate to the base layer of
ps plus
it translates to
partially the middle layer which is more
money
and the top layer which includes the
streaming part of ps now
so so if i have a ps now game
that but i don't have the ps
plus middle tier
yes there's a chance that that game that
i had on ps now won't work because i'm
hearing licensing i'm hearing some
licensing issues and people getting
error codes as a result of it and i
think it's looking at it as another skew
right so it's like okay you had siphon
filter back during the ps3 days of ps
now ps plus comes out
and now i can't play the game unless i
buy playstation it's like they still
haven't figured out that handshake very
well so but i still care
okay the entire discussion here is is
the problem of this i think it is just
way too complicated when you have to
make like charts that big to explain
okay if you have that you can do that
but you have to upgrade here and then
i i don't get that why not make it easy
simple if you want to introduce that new
subscription service and how much sony
ever did anything easy and simple yeah
so i don't know it's the way they
translate it i don't know if if it just
translates to the top tier or the again
because again the downloadable stuff is
kind of what the middle tier of ps plus
is now right and and the streaming stuff
only exists in that top tier now so
either way it's something that you would
be paying and i don't
somebody in the chat maybe uh
get me this information
what do you what do they translate what
do they move you to if you just have ps
now and you want to go over to ps plus
what level does that translate you to
because again it may translate
translate you to the proper level so you
don't have to pay extra for that but i'm
not sure again if that handshake is
working properly right and
and again if for whatever reason they're
just not transferring all those games
over which would make sense and i could
go back to the licensing thing i just
think
because the ps plus thing is a different
product from ps now
like you said like since anything might
my hair should be an issue but the
handshake might be an issue i shot them
a boy mystic he has said that um the
only thing i did see was that some
some publishers are not honoring that
handshake license that you've already
had so like if you had like resident
evil one or something like that again
prior
then you ain't may not be able to get it
and again you have to subscribe to the
new service yeah that again to boxing
burger's point again this is from what i
i need comment this is kings time i i
need more confirmation before i say
definitively whatever but i did see
these comments i did see you know people
having issue you know and i will say
this is funny i'm not trying to counsel
i have to say this it's funny because
i'm a tech effect so i want to know
where tekken is so i'm like where's
attacking that well checking is in the
tekken tekken was never sort of
re-released for the ps4 right so that's
in the top tier you mean second two
second two yeah it's in
i don't know what happened with the
handshake this part is funny i have to
say like tekken 2 at one point this week
whatever was for ten thousand dollars
yeah yeah
i was like so he was like yo what the
what the hell take place why is this 10
grand
i thought that was funny i have to
now i clearly it must have been
corrected but there's a handshake issue
going on yeah i think the same happened
yeah um ape escape maybe skip for like
ten thousand dollars or something but
how did they get to that price
i don't know how did that happen
growing up growing pains i get the
growing pain stuff right but again it's
like
why are you coming in this hot just
delay the service until you have it more
set in stone like so i guess you know
they they're gonna handle their bumps
kind of kind of along the along the way
and fix it along the way
um
the uh the top tier when it comes to
classic games is sparse to say the least
um there is some stuff that has trophy
support which is cool um i did not
really expect that um and
luckily i think everything that we're
getting in that regard are 60 hertz
games so we are getting ntsc games we
don't have to worry about that crazy 50
hertz stuff that
that we were having issues with so all
in all like
i think
it's just like at the start of game pass
it's not exactly where it should needs
to be i think that middle tier for
people who haven't been in the
playstation ecosystem before
is is premium because you get a lot of
stuff there um
but yeah i mean it's there's some
growing pains there but yeah the losing
game stuff i just don't see why they
didn't put an a definitive end date to
ps now
and migrate people over because again
it just doesn't make a whole lot of
sense you migrate people over
the thing about it is that when
microsoft did this they realized hey you
know oh people are buying whatever 10
years worth of you know what they allow
the staff yeah gold and whatever and it
translates to whatever you know game
passes
um
playstation didn't want that to happen
so they you know a lot of people that
stack stuff
uh they had to initially got blocked and
then some of that stuff they they went
back on a little bit but you're still
not necessarily getting your money's
worth
so it's a whole bunch of stuff and it
comes down to money um
but at the end of the day i think
they're to have to eat this and kind of
fix it and make it right for the
consumers and then move everybody over
and just make it a smoother transition
as possible obviously the end goal is to
eliminate ps now as a as its own service
right i just don't see why they just you
know
just just cut the band-aid off now and
that's it yeah boxing burger and then
right
yeah
i mean
i'm with uh soft i i don't
get
the way how they turn want to transition
people over if if we look at
how xbox did it yeah they probably lost
a little bit of money but they didn't
get any negative press attached to this
and if you want to establish a new
subscription service out there
you kind of want to make it as easy and
welcoming as possible um
and that just
seems weird to me how how so sony did it
they didn't allowed for for allow for
the purchasing of the ps plus
subscriptions now for three months or so
so that people can stack and stuff like
that um just weird to me um nevertheless
um like soft said um i think that middle
tier is especially if you're not
subscribed to game pass and
are only in the
sony ecosystem pretty good value um
i was a bit surprised by how good their
first offering actually is the first
party games to put in there is upgrade
so yeah we'll we shall see how this will
develop um
i just don't like i said earlier i don't
like the how complex everything seems to
be these days uh on
the sony side but yeah uh overall it is
gonna be a i think a pretty good value
um
even without the day and date uh
discussion which i'm not gonna start now
it's still
still a good value because there are
simply a lot of games for you to play so
yeah enough
rand outdoor
what's going on i mean i really don't
have anything to add up outside of what
boxberg and sovereign have talked about
regarding this so i don't really know
much about the whole playstation
tier thing in the playstation i wish
king was here that's what i said man for
the record people coming at me
i didn't come back
cam and her explain it this would be
fair he wasn't going to explain it yeah
would have to do it
but like i don't know i don't have the
information so i'm asking people because
i was so for people who shout out to my
boy face twenty three he's like god
you're spreading i didn't say anything
yeah that's not my goal
he's like you're spreading
misinformation i'm like bro i didn't
even talk yet i just saw it what'd you
call it tonight but okay so what's
what's the misinformation
he said face is saying that they they um
they migrated everybody over you know
what i'm saying i haven't tested the
service out so i can't make the
definition if they migrated everyone
over
then is ps now dead
and there's no ps now because that's not
the indication we're getting again i
have it i just haven't turned on my
machine so i haven't i haven't engaged
with it right i'm just going by stuff
that i've heard right right it already
launched in the u.s right yeah right
yeah so for me i can't comment until i i
see i'm just going over what king's
article he brought to our attention i'm
just reiterating what is what he brought
that's what it is but anyway
i hear what you're saying right like you
haven't you have too much to add to this
pretty much it says because if you go to
playstation now on playstation.com
it says notice playstation now has
merged with playstation plus and is no
longer available as a standalone
membership
benefits that were part of playstation
now are part of the various membership
plans options available in playstation
plus customers who had an active
playstation on membership on the new
playstation plus membership service
launch were migrated over to the
playstation press plus premium
so it's just saying that in the
migration in the migration everybody's
moved over in the migration there were
games lost in the end yeah so there is
no more standalone playstation now okay
and when they merged them
yeah i guess they lost 200 games or
whatever i mean i don't know uh so
that's that's what playstation.com says
yeah so then yeah i think the thing that
makes sense is the licensing stuff
whereas playstation plus plus whatever
the heck it's called is called now is a
new service and the licenses have to be
renegotiated
there you go
there you have it
attic
expert in this uh topic where what's
your thoughts just prime example of sony
doing stuff they shouldn't be doing as
quick as they shouldn't be doing that's
all i got to really say about it yeah
and this you know funny thing is that
this stuff does kind of matter because
just i remember when the um what is it
nvidia
the nvidia
streaming stuff they put stuff on there
kind of even it just has a test bed in
their beta sort of stages that once they
once the the service came out properly
they they were they added to a big beef
with the game devs and then the
publishers they're like no you don't
have you have permission to do use it
for this aspect you can't assume that it
can just transfer over to the actual
sort of service when the service goes
live and not think that we have to don't
have to renegotiate rights and money and
stuff like that so
yeah i can see how a bunch of games just
sort of fell off the planet
with this chance yeah right i wish king
was here because this is i would love to
know where king was going gonna go with
this oh my god clearly this is something
he wanted to talk about yeah i have not
got a chance to test out the service to
confirm you know what he was gonna say
or not so i'm just curious that i shot
the king he's in the beast and with them
damn crocs and he can explain himself
further then it comes back
that's all i got anyway moving on that's
the last joint you want to get all the
super chats don't want me to get to the
poll and then we'll get about it yeah i
get the super chats
uh let me see
lucasfox but no no we got that donald
taco no if
you know i said nope thx 1138 five
dollar switch sony took my top tier ps
plus on ps4 and downgraded me to a ps
plus essential tier on ps5 classic sony
moon dripping gamers this generic this
generation yeah question i i'm not the
biggest familiar because i haven't even
really turned on my playstation in a
little bit um is
what's going on with the
what's what i'm looking for what's up um
like when you when you naturally go from
playstation plus don't they naturally
put you in the highest tier
if you had now and plus you go directly
to the type to the highest tier
that's crazy because
that means
i mean i guess you would have to because
it's like i said like playstation now is
just some elaborate scheme to to pay
more for less for for the same amount of
uh
of content that you have like literally
that's all they did is break playstation
now into two different tiers and put it
on playstation plus
and and so it's like if you have both of
them you're gonna be paying
i mean i guess it'll be about the same
10 bucks each 20 bucks
but
it's just it's crazy that
they would offer the highest tier and i
bet you they won't even tell those
people that they have the highest tier
until it's time to renew you know what
i'm saying it's clear that all i know is
that it's clear that they definitely
want to get
you know the playstation plus service
that that's where they're going to that
to me that's all it's amazing migration
from what i see so i need to start when
i test it i will get more further
information on it but i'm dying to know
what king had to say about this what i
think
i think
i think this this was a giant elaborate
scheme to
make playstation not like hide the
playstation now numbers like you know
this service wasn't doing the greatest
let's merge it with playstation plus
so you know because it was like what
three to five million is as high as that
service ever went to
but now it's looking like it's the
hottest service out there
what i'm hearing though is that the the
streaming stuff is actually working
better as well so i don't know if that
you know behind the scenes they you know
they they did do that sort of migrate
migration started using more of the
azure stuff because
as it stood like it's still you know ps
now on its own whenever i tried it just
did not run well with the gigabit
connection to me it's just as simple as
combining two services consolidation
that that to me is what it is and if you
have one service that's doing well and
then you have another service that may
not have been you know doing as well you
combine them now they're trying to offer
value and then produce the tears the key
is going to be you know what the back of
that stuff gets straightened out the
licensing stuff gets straightened out
they continue to bring good value to it
we do know they're doing day and date
it's excuse me not day and day but
they're doing like it seems like a year
out after some of the exclusives are
coming in there you know what i mean
we've seen return return on all the
stuff
i thought that's good i thought that's
good value you know i mean so it's up to
them i think they they're not ever going
to be on the day and date train right
now you know who knows what if that
changes but right now this model works
for them yeah but they are doing you
know second party third-party deals
straight is going to be yeah trey's
going to be in there day one so you know
smaller stuff again it's it's a it's a
growing process so i think you know
if they see the numbers
and they and it behooves them we'll
start seeing more and more
uh get closer to that first party stuff
and like we said in the past i think the
free anything the the service based
games that they have in the pipeline i
think it would be stupid not to put in
this service that would be my prediction
and that's where i think the bungee
relationship really will pay off with
the live services games that they intend
to to bring into service so that's all i
got kidding you i missed for that
because i definitely want to hear what
you got but we got to get some chance to
get up out of here
ready to roll
good now that was the last one all right
cool i'll do the poll um with the final
fantasy 7 25th anniversary event
showcasing final fantasy 7 rebirth as a
playstation 5 exclusive do you think
it's fair that xbox is missing out on
this title the choices are a yes
secretly extended exclusivity deals just
to gatekeep the game off xbox is unfair
to xbox fans and the success and the
overall success of the game
b
no exclusives bring identity to each
platform if you truly care about the
game buy the game where the platform
exists
or c i don't care y'all better keep that
same energy if it's a game y'all care
about
shout out to all the people
forwards gonna go up shout out to rand
outdoor 19 amen with the million pulling
up for the aftermath show boxing burger
jazz caught in the whole crew
pulling up let's start with you ran an
absolute pleasure to be in the realm
once again what you got going on what
can they find you sir
yeah it's always uh
wait am i muted no no i'm not good
you're good okay i'm good we'll hear
everything wasn't sure okay
hey are you sure are you sure attic
is king
yes
yeah uh thanks for having me on again
it's always
it's always amazing to come on
into the realm of the lords to talk
about uh all the uh
important topics of the day uh yeah you
know where you can find me youtube.com
slash randolphore19
uh videos and uh you know xbox two with
jess gordon
usually fridays sometimes saturdays
sometimes sundays
i don't think we've ever done sunday to
be fair we've never done sunday we have
done monday a couple times but yeah
we did we did monday this past week
because we had to talk about the
showcase so
thank you guys for having me it's always
a blast and uh
you know uh yeah never believe me when i
talk about my predictions i guess ever
again
cox said you think i did this one
intentionally yeah
jump off that i'm with jazz jazz when i
listened i think you'd be deep faking
that's why i put it in your intro i was
like
because he got cuz what it is he got the
playbook so he want to act like he got
all of it so you don't have one that you
know all right that don't probably ain't
gonna happen right now you know what to
say just to make you see make it seem
honest like oh it's a prediction like it
could happen it couldn't happen
i'm with jazz i think it's deeper than
rap with you
he ain't answering too he's quiet
i got red quiet that's funny anyway he
just gave us the laughter
but anyway salute to my man boxing
burger aka formerly you know the artist
formerly known as archimedes my god
germany in the building i get those
correct pronunciations which i love
great show love what you're doing with
your channel you had you had a big game
going on with uh with you with prior to
the showcase waking to find people find
you what you got going on man
yeah first thanks for the spontaneous
invite
pulling me out of the pool
here i needed their perspective yes
always fun to be on here so thanks for
the invite and yeah people can find me
everywhere on the boxing burger
twitter youtube xbox playstation
everywhere um and like you said i do
have uh this little podcast each and
every thursday the world of gaming um
always having fun this week i have uh
luke
lore
yeah i get the ghost yeah it's gonna be
fun
it's gonna be fun and
um yeah uh
i hope to be back here soon man thanks i
had a blast i absolutely see you up in
there i was like you know what i think
it'd be really good to get some
different perspectives especially you
know for my international german
brothers you know what i'm saying and
know how they're feeling about certain
things always good to get different
perspectives so salute to you for
pulling up last minute you already know
and of course
my man
the
what you the quarry with the girlfriend
streams uh the lord addict what's going
on with you man what you got going on
that's a man like so
the reason i was late is because i don't
know somehow well first off i i i
i think i like
yesterday when i got off playing
demio with me i was fine and then like
30 40 minutes after that like i i felt
like like i was dying like and then this
morning
i i guess like i was half asleep and i
was moving my head and i hit the the
window
that i have like i hit it hard like i
was there for a minute i thought i had a
concussion like it was not bad
and then like i took i took some some
advil to go to sleep i was like if i die
my sleep
it was that painful i was like i gotta
like i gotta go to sleep
and then i wake up and well i don't know
why but i thought it was much later than
it was and i woke up and i was like well
i guess i missed the iop and then i saw
what time it was i was like you know
what like i don't feel exactly like that
so let me jump on i appreciate it man
glad you're doing better like i said i
know you gave me the kind of heads up
that it might be spooky till the next
morning so i had to feel i'm glad you're
all right and don't go to sleep with
your head hurting like that's scary
somebody what's going to pass away like
that sagging yeah you can't yeah you
can't you can't do that
yeah that's scary bro take something for
it stand for a little bit settle in and
then when you get the pain because yeah
you know we don't want nothing to happen
that actually gave me a little scare um
salute to you salute obviously the
stream sell salute to um all the stuff
you've been putting up prior to that and
stuff like that and uh of course
so it's all very spicy today
uh what am i doing oh so i will be on
vacation next week uh
all right so i will not be around so it
could be it could be i guess yeah it'd
be a little bit to see me again but uh
should we apologize
for the super chats that we got yeah
please do that yeah please do that my
apologies for leaving you in the hands
of these two that's it
look we're gonna try it out appreciate i
appreciate my brother so old to be down
uh but yeah i i need the r and r i'm so
i'm so happy king is finally taking it
yeah
so yeah man i just sometimes just got to
disconnect and i have been way way too
connected so i'm glad to be able to get
some rest um
beyond that so yeah happy father's day
to everybody um i'm gonna hang out with
my dad a little bit after i record this
uh lord's minute
lyric yeah papasaw will see him a little
bit and tomorrow i'll be taking him to
see uh the second best baseball team in
new york city
oh oh mean you mean the yankees y'all
gonna say
you know
the team in queens you know oh
oh okay okay little slander i see you're
taking him to what he want to see though
right what he want to see his people
say i got it that's father's day so it's
funny
all the children are going so even
kaibatsu who does oh he just rises
oh take a picture i want to see his face
at the baseball game this is going to be
hilarious to be fair i think we might as
well just say now the week after next
there won't be an iop yeah because we
all have a little we all again just we
try to do better mental health you know
been doing this since 2017
we rarely miss you know what i'm saying
and um you know we're going to try to do
better about it obviously soft is going
to take some time king took some time
this week addict we would have him take
some time i'll take some time so that
one after was yes we pre-emptively not
next week next week we'll be here but
the week after after yeah the week after
you don't take a little hard time
because we gotta we have a new model if
there's if half of us are missing a show
then we're just going to cancel that
show absolutely we got to do better
about our mental health you know what
i'm saying i know rand you know well
about it you know
same thing with jazz today like shout
out to jesus was supposed to make it you
know he was going to come on chaz was
going to come we're going back and forth
and um i was just like no brother you
know you i'd rather you rest he had like
a migraine and he wasn't he's going
through it let's rest we will be here
man so so but we don't get we're still
going to give y'all something addict me
right we still talked about giving us
something on the lord's day so it's not
like you're gonna leave with absolutely
nothing but we wanted to just be clear
about that so that's it for solving yeah
send some love to king man make sure you
call him out on those crocs
ken crocker's outside make sure you give
him king cry all the slander but uh yeah
man that's all i got anything else
before we get up out of here man
all right that's about it that's about
it yo everybody enjoy your sunday we
catch you happy father's day salute to
the fathers out there much love in the
room and we are outta here peace
[Music]
we gotta come back tom for your super
chat
we are live some someone has something
to say
let me play with your joystick five
dollar super chat no sob tweaks in a row
my apology well it's gonna be one week
cause you won't have a show the second
week so my apologies but you know i'll
be waiting for that steam deck in the
mail though
me and uh
me and king will still be around that
week me and keem might stream a game or
something if he wants to do it all right
no doubt see we gave let me play with
you 36 kiss bars for some yeah
we really out peace
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
uh